why in the world should we assume that
the topic of your book the title of your
book refers to something that is real
and
and if it's real why aren't we attending
to it and why is it important
you know
well first of all it's real
because in all 56 of the largest
developed nations boys are falling
behind girls in almost every single
academic subject um including reading
and writing which are the two biggest
predictors of success or failure as you
can probably imagine
um and so and and
and boys who do badly in those subjects
are much more likely to drop out of high
school boys in general are much more
likely to drop out of high school
especially in the united states and boys
who drop out of high school are more
than 20 percent likely to be unemployed
in their 20s um
this is a statistic before covet
when the unemployment rate in the united
states was 3.4 percent uh versus more
than 20 percent for boys
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased to be talking
today with dr warren farrell who i spoke
with three years ago almost to the day
about his previous book why
why men earn more we're going to talk
today about the boy crisis which was
published just after our last interview
so that's in 2018 dr warren farrell
was chosen by the financial times as one
of the world's top 100 thought leaders
his books have been published in more
than 50 countries and in 19 different
languages they include the new york
times bestseller why men are the way
they are which must be a very thick book
plus the international bestseller the
myth of male power his most recent is
the boy crisis we mentioned why men earn
more as well which is a very good book
his most recent is the boy crisis as i
said 2018 co-authored with john gray the
boy crisis was chosen as a finalist for
the forward indies award which is the
independent publishers award
dr farrell has been a pioneer in both
the women's movement elected three times
to the board of the national
organization of women in new york city
and the men's movement called by gq
magazine the martin luther king of the
men's movement he conducts couples
communications workshops nationwide and
he's appeared on over a thousand tv
shows that's way too many tv shows
and has been interviewed by oprah
barbara walters peter jennings katie
couric larry king tucker carlson regis
philbin
and charlie rose
he's frequently written for and been
featured in the new york times
and other major publications worldwide
he has two daughters lives with his wife
in mill valley california and resides
virtually at www.warrenferal.com
as i said we spoke three years ago it
was may 6 2018. just before dr farrell's
book the boy crisis
was published we'll concentrate today on
this book and associated topics hello
warren it's so good to see you it is so
good to see you more than normal jordan
for all the you know it's not we've had
more than the boy crisis we've had the
jordan peterson crisis obviously uh yeah
a very dull topic that
i don't know i i it's just amazing to me
that during this process um of you
going through what you went through not
only with yourself but with michaela
with tammy that you're
not only alive but that you're also that
you also produced an extraordinary book
um as well in the in that period of time
it's just beyond me no thank you yeah
well it helped keep me afloat so i've
been reviewing the boy crisis in in
quite a bit of detail over the last few
days
it's
it's something i haven't thought about
for a while uh
certainly i've thought about it since
our last conversation
the world has twisted and turned in all
sorts of strange ways since then and i
suppose this issue has been pushed this
particular issue
the boy crisis let's say
has been pushed to the back burner in a
major way by all sorts of well cultural
movements and by covid and it's not
precisely on the radar you mentioned to
me just when we were discussing this
issue for example begin at the beginning
of our conversation today
before we started taping that uh
president biden established a white
house gender policy council which is
supposed to focus on gender issues but
in your opinion pretty much only focuses
on women and girls and is also supposed
to focus on race but pretty much ignores
black boys which is perhaps the
intersectional place to use a detestable
phrase where the crisis is the most
noticeable
so
why in the world should we assume that
the topic of your book the title of your
book refers to something that is real
and
and if it's real why aren't we attending
to it and why is it important
you know as well first of all it's real
because in all 56 of the largest
developed nations boys are falling
behind girls in almost every single
academic subject
including reading and writing which are
the two biggest predictors of success or
failure as you can probably imagine
um and so and and
and boys who do badly in those subjects
are much more likely to drop out of high
school boys in general are much more
likely to drop out of high school
especially in the united states and boys
who drop out of high school are more
than 20 percent likely to be unemployed
in their 20s um
this is a statistic before covet
when the unemployment rate in the united
states was 3.4 percent uh versus more
than twenty percent for boys um and so
that's just the academic part of it on
the mental health part of it uh when
boys and girls are nine they commit
suicide about equally and very minimally
between the edges ages of 10
and 14 boys commit suicide twice as
often as girls
between the ages of 15 and 19 they
commit suicide four times as often as
girls between the ages of 20 and 25 they
commit suicide about five times as often
as girls and most people don't even know
this pay attention to this but this is
only the the tip of the iceberg of the
mental health issue um there's
where boys are far more likely to
die from drug overdoses opioid overdoses
they're far more likely to be depressed
if you measure depression depression in
a way that includes male symptoms of
depression
much much more likely to
um
enter into um
place places that that take care of
people who are
mentally have mental problems and so on
um and and when boys and so i started
asking myself you know what what causes
all this you know and and when i first
submitted uh the boy crisis to the
publisher and sort of um in form of
proposal
i outlined 10 causes and those causes
included the environment and schools and
so on
but i kept coming back to realizing that
the hub cause of the boy crisis
was
was dead deprivation that the boy crisis
resides where dads do not reside and so
that um got me really thinking about
that so for example
boys
who are raised by moms and dads together
and go from an intact family to a school
that has very few male teachers
there's not a huge impact a little bit
of an impact that's negative but not
much
but if they go from a female only
home environment have only a female role
model that then they go to a school with
almost no male teacher role models uh
they are much more subjected to much
more vulnerable
to being seduced by gangs as a as a
pseudo family or china not having the
postponed gratification that dads tend
to bring to the family and so therefore
without that postponed gratification
they're more vulnerable to a drug dealer
saying you can make you know money
really easily
by dealing drugs you don't have to worry
about getting the best grades in school
and you'll you'll prove everybody that
you're you know you'll drive around in a
nice car you'll be able to get the girls
you can't get because you're
you're sort of a loser at school etc so
i just started looking at all these
things i saw that the sperm count of
boys
had dropped 50 percent that the iqs of
boys had dropped 15
and just i started you know looking and
wondering about you know
two things one is how amazed how how
much evidence there was for the boy
crisis and the second was exactly the
question you asked
since it's so evident and we're so
focused on girls and women's issues why
are we not even seeing the the boys and
men's issues that are coming up and how
damaging it is to women
to not have father involvement for
example uh women that i had dated
between my marriages
were constantly talking about being
overwhelmed um and so women are losers
by father's not being involved fathers
feel a lack of purpose um and they they
deal with the whole thing that you talk
about
in your first rule of you know not
having um not having some type of change
of culture where there's a vitality to
give them uh to give them purpose and so
we're
in a very uh challenging situation i did
come to understand what the cause of it
is
but but it really is depressing to see
how
ubiquitous that causes
so why do you think if the crisis is of
the magnitude that you suggest
um you you you
cite some statistics in the early part
of your book um
more men in the uk have died by suicide
in the past year than all british
soldiers in all wars since 1945
suicide now takes more lives than war
murder and natural disasters around the
world combined that might not include
covid i presume that statistic stealing
more than 36 million years of healthy
life and the rate of suicide is growing
much faster for men than for women
you mentioned that boys iq has dropped
about 15 points since the 1980s and make
a case in your book that that's related
to fatherlessness we'll get back into
that boys scored lower than girls in the
63 largest developed nations in which
the pisa a set of international standard
tests was given boys are 50 percent more
likely than girls to fail to meet basic
proficiency in any of the three core
subjects of reading math and science by
eighth grade in the us forty percent of
girls are at least proficient in writing
compared to one in five boys
one in five
boys who perform as well as girls are
graded less favorably you know we did
some research years ago showing that
agreeable
children get better grades than their iq
would predict and girls are more
agreeable than boys and so what that
means is if you're
less agreeable and more likely to be
troubled then because that is associated
with being less agreeable then
you're graded more harshly than your
pure cognitive ability would predict and
that probably accounts for the gender
difference or at least for part of it
and not that it particularly matters but
um
boys have gone from 61 of university
degrees to 39 percent girls the reverse
percent of boys who say they don't like
school has gone up 70 since 1980 i
imagine it was already pretty high in
boys are expelled from school three
times as often and girls as girls that's
the same statistic basically as boys are
more likely to be arrested for conduct
disorder juvenile delinquency men are
much more likely to be imprisoned
it's the same pattern there
one in three children in the uk and the
u.s grow up without a father
and you know our culture pushes the idea
constantly that all families are of
equal virtue let's say
and i suppose that's justified in that
it's
self-evident that
of all the things that people strive to
do well in their lives they strive to
raise their children i would say more
diligently than
than than they might meet any other
requirement or responsibility and so it
seems cruel to
judge the quality of the family given
the commitment that it takes for example
to be a single parent but i i'm
releasing a podcast this week with
richard trombley who's perhaps the
world's foremost authority on the
development of aggression in children
development and regulation and he his
data certainly indicates that having a
single mother especially a single mother
with issues
is uh
a predictor of the maintenance of
aggressive behavior throughout the
lifespan a major predictor now he
associates that more with uh
trouble
on the maternal side
young mothers young uneducated mothers
young uneducated mothers with
psychiatric and other health
difficulties who lack social support
he hasn't concentrated so much on the
fatherlessness end of it but
the upshot is or the takeaway is the
same these are these are families that
are not producing
children who
have the same probability of thriving
let's say
you said also japan has increased its
vocational education programs
so that 23 percent of its high school
graduates graduate study at vocational
schools and they have a 99.6 employment
rate that's something we can talk about
as well so your your book is
peppered with
well
painful statistics i would say
um
why do you think we don't attend to this
warren
i think historically and biologically um
men were programmed um and
and really
through animals including insects right
on through to human beings
we were programmed to be able to be
willing to die
in order to get women's love and so in
every generation had its war and in each
generation's war we said some version of
uncle sam needs you and we pointed to
the uncle who in the marine uniform on
the on the count on the on the mantle
and we were so proud of him he died in
world war one or two and the boy sees
that the way he can get love and
approval and respect even though he's
being criticized by this person or that
person or in school or at home um is he
can he can he can be a soldier and so we
give it we inspire
boys to be disposable um and we and we
and and
when somebody is likely to be lost um
that you do you don't develop as much
emotional attachment uh to that person
and if you if you're if your way of
surviving
is for
males to
be willing to lose their life so we're
not under nazi rule etc you begin to
develop a connection between caring
about
men
largely to the degree that they are
willing to protect women and die for
women and so you don't care about the
people who are dying so much if you have
a an incentive
in there
incentive to have them be willing to die
in order to protect you and so
so it's a disposable male hypothesis
that would be the hypothesis on the
evolutionary psychology front i mean one
of the things i've noticed is that
my my critics let's say
like to parody my audience as
well angry white and young and male
let's say um
but
the thing that's interesting about that
is that
perhaps you could give me the benefit of
the doubt and say that if that is my
audience and my audience is certainly
much broader than that and that wasn't
who i was targeting let's say but even
if it was well
is there something wrong with talking to
those people who are alienated and angry
and perhaps for some genuine reason
the answer seems to be the default
answer seems to be they're so
contemptible that anyone who even tries
to help them is to be regarded with
extreme suspicion and it seems to me
that that's in some manner a reflection
of the phenomenon that you're discussing
which is a very uh
what would you say if it's
it's very deeply rooted and fundamental
at least from one perspective
so you know i was thinking today maybe
our culture set up so that
the most
esteemed people
are highly successful men but the least
esteemed people are
unsuccessful men
and so maybe maybe that maybe that's the
strange paradox is that
men so in some sense have it the best if
they're
occupying the pinnacle of achievement
but they have it the worst if they're
at the bottom of the heap
and that seems right if you look at
women's dating preferences for example
compared to men
women disproportionately are
disproportionately attracted to
successful men and disproportionately
likely even to rank men of average
attainment as below average uh whether
it's attractiveness or or any of the
other uh criteria by which such things
might be judged
so you know the question is if it is so
deeply rooted
well one question is if it's so deeply
rooted
what makes you think there's anything
that we can do about it i mean you
haven't had any luck for example
convincing the white house over years to
to pay some attention to
boys essentially even though they're the
problem let's say
you might think that even from the
perspective of prevention there would be
some some
attention paid in that direction but
this
bias is so pervasive that it seems to
even interfere with that
absolutely so a few things lots of
really good things you brought up so let
me deal with the first thing on the
anger issue um
one of the um i don't know
if we've discussed this before jordan
but i've been teaching couples
communication workshops for 30 years and
just produced a thirty a zoom course on
that a few a few days ago
and one of the things that is
fundamental to that course
is um is that
men and women and this is gay couples as
well and trans couples and um and even
parents and children all complain about
their partners or their parents or their
child's anger
and almost
and one of the things that i work with
them on is to understand that anger
is vulnerabilities mask
and the moment you see your partner as
angry
look for the vulnerability that created
that anger that felt the fact that they
felt rejected or the possibility that
they felt rejected the possibility that
they felt misunderstood the possibility
that they said what they feel their
bother that bothers them over and over
again but that it's been ignored and
every time that they say that uh say
what bothers them uh there's a response
to it that disconnect that cuts cuts
them off and interrupts them before they
finish their full feeling they're not
drawn out and the response that they
get is an argument and so they tend to
not bring up issues that really concern
them because it's only going to be met
by an argument that will escalate the
problem and so they end up walking on
eggshells now who does that men women
both sexes do that and it doesn't make
any difference whether it's straight or
gay couples they both do this is a
complaint that i hear from literally
everybody um and so when when your
audience is is um criticized as being
angry i would just ask you know if you
if you look at that anger as the
vulnerability how is that audience not
being heard and the way you are serving
that audience is to hear some if to the
degree that that audience is part of
part of your audience is is is serving
that audience by healing them by having
them have a place where they feel heard
as opposed to dismissed when someone
feels dismissed they become
depressed they become they turn inward
an example of that is when men and
fathers and mothers go through the
family court system
fathers are much less likely to feel
heard and the family courts feel treated
as equals well that's another reason why
i wanted to talk to you
before and today in my clinical practice
i had men
who were fine upstanding men who were
absolutely ground into
nothing by the family court system i
mean i
pulled all the tricks i had out of my
hat one client in particular
a medical professional who whose life
was completely destroyed by the family
law system it was like watching a train
wreck in slow motion to use a terrible
cliche
we tried every trick in the book to keep
him afloat what he wanted was 50 access
to his three kids and he was a really
good father i went out with him a number
of times with his kids and watched how
he interacted with them and how he
taught them and and and how he cared for
them and went to his house and looked at
how he set up their bedroom and and he
did this guy did everything right he was
extremely high in conscientiousness so
unsurprising but um
you know he had his driver's license
taken away he had his passport taken
away he had his livelihood demolished by
ill-founded rumors by a spouse that was
hell-bent on his destruction i mean we
even went so far as to have him pick up
his kids
when when they made the switch in front
of a really really busy supermarket she
would pull up behind him right in front
of the doors of the supermarket the kids
would come out she would stay in the car
the kids would come out and go into his
truck and pull away so that everything
that transpired between the two of them
was in full
public view all the time and despite
that she managed to get into his car a
number of times but anyways he he he he
was just demolished and i've seen this
and you know i get criticized maybe
maybe we can go into this a little bit
i get criticized for a couple of things
by men
um
regularly
one is i get criticized because i stand
up for traditional marriage and there's
always a proportion of men who write and
i they're usually men who've been
demolished by the family court system
who say look you should stop telling
young men to
adopt a permanent relationship get
married
because the family court system is so
um
prejudiced against men
that
to sign a marriage contract
if you sign it with the wrong person is
you know tantamount to a
well let's not call it a death warrant
but
but it's a very bad idea you know and my
my response to that is well you're
basically married if you live together
for six months anyways and so i don't
see how the marriage actually adds to
that you know in terms of in terms of
risk um
but there it's not like i don't
understand that there's a point there
and it's so it's interesting because i
do believe that the family court system
i've looked at it i've been involved in
it several times
wasn't to my benefit i would say
[Music]
the men have the men who are objecting
have a point and then i'm also
suggesting to young men another point of
criticism that
you know they adopt traditional
responsibilities to the degree that
that's possible and that that's where
they'll find meaning but
you know
some of your work makes me
second-guess that at least to some
degree
wondering if
i just don't see an alternative i
suppose that's really the issue is that
well what do we have we have our jobs we
have our careers we have our loved ones
we have our families
that's life and if you don't have that
well then you're adrift that's the
purpose void that you talk about in this
in this book
um but if the traditional
pathways to meaning let's say are no
longer reliable
what's a guy to do
let's say we we really we really so
to affirm what you're saying and put a
piece of data to that uh when people are
going through the family court system
mothers and fathers are going through
the family court system
the father is eight times as likely as
the mother to commit suicide
from the frustration obviously of not
feeling able to connect to his
his children what what very few mothers
and fathers understand
is that you know
dads have adopted in their traditional
role sort of a father's catch-22 they
learn to earn money they learn to love
their family by being away from the love
of their family uh they often do things
like they may drive cabs they may um
they may quit their passion of being an
elementary school teacher becoming a
superintendent or a principal in schools
they hate they hate administration
but they end up earning more money
because they want their children to do
better than they had a chance to do in
their life they want their children to
go to a good school which means a good
school district which means a more
expensive home which means that if they
were a musician or an actor
or a writer or that elementary school
teacher they have to give up that for
the most part because they'll earn more
doing something that they like less and
so
right which is something that which is
part of the pay gap that's never really
emphasized is that one of the ways you
earn more and you outlined that in in i
think
a great book why men earn more i think
that is a great book um
you know you point out that you earn
more for doing jobs that are less
desirable intrinsically desirable in
some sense i mean that's part of the
equation at least their jobs are more
dangerous they take you away from home
more often etc and those are
disproportionately male jobs i mean the
guy that i saw who got demolished so
badly you know his wife claimed to be
the primary caregiver and the courts are
tilted so that they favor the mother
especially in the first three years of a
child's life and i've had some sympathy
for that perspective um
for a variety of reasons although i
think i've i think i've rethought my
stance and believe that 50 50 custody
default is the appropriate
default um uh just like 5050 default
with regards to money or during the uh
life of the marriage is the default
um but my my client worked a lot uh to
provide for his family and so and his
wife stayed at home
and was with the kids all the time as a
consequence and because of that when
they went to court she had the upper
hand in the
um
in the in the custody negotiation
because the judge believed perhaps that
it was in the best interest of the
children that they continue with their
primary caregiver and that's a very hard
argument to
to
push aside
given the strength of the mother child
bond especially in the first
especially in the first year i mean
maybe maybe the first year is
exceptional
perhaps it's not perhaps we have to move
to 50 50 regardless but what do you
think about that
there's four one of the things that i
talk about in the boy crisis is the four
must do's of do after divorce
and this is like i'm now putting huge
amounts of research together into sort
of four simple things
um but one the number one and most
important is that the children have an
equal amount by the way this is if you
want the children to do almost as well
as they would in an intact family not as
well but almost as well okay so this is
a child sent see that's something we
should establish here too as a principal
my sense is always marriage is for
children not for adults exactly they're
the primary they're the primary target
of
of uh
of rank ordered importance children
first and then then the adults marriages
for children not for adults that's
that's a very immature way of looking at
the world if you think your marriage is
for you you're you have a free choice
when you have children to have the
children and not have the children
that's like having a free choice to take
the job or not take the job but once you
take the job you take the
responsibilities with it and um and so
so in court when i talk about i do a lot
of expert witness work on this issue and
in court what i explained is that we now
we now for the first time in the last
five or six years we now have really
incontrovertible evidence that four
things are really needed if we want the
children to do the best
to divorce number one is an equal amount
of time with mother and father the
closer you get to 50 50 even when the
child is like a one year old or just
born it is that is um that leads to the
greatest possibility of a positive
outcome on so many measures that we'd
have to spend almost a half hour talking
about those well i'd like i would like
to talk about that to some degree
because it's it's somewhat
counter-intuitive so i think it's
important to delve into that
absolutely and i'll be happy to do that
okay um and then number two um is that
the father and mother live within about
20 minutes drive time from each other
because when they don't oftentimes and
become very resentful of the other
parent because they have to go to that
other parents home and
miss their soccer practice so therefore
they don't get the skills and the
teamwork and the continuity to be good
on the soccer team or miss their best
friend's birthday party or whatever um
and so there's a tension when the father
and mother live after divorce more than
about 20 minutes drive time from each
other
number third number three is that the
children cannot um experience any bad
mouthing or
negative body language from mom toward
dad dad toward mom because when the
child looks in the mirror and let's say
the child's a boy and um
hears that your father is irresponsible
and your father's a liar your father
is this and that that boy is looking in
the mirror and saying well maybe i'm a
narcissist like my dad well the boys
young boys play dad
and so whatever they think of as dad is
going to be is be going to enter their
space of fantasy and i mean what they
play out in their fantasy play is their
destiny yes and so
that image of of future masculinity i
mean i always think of captain hook when
i think of that because peter pan stays
peter pan because he doesn't want to be
captain hook
and it's a brilliant it's brilliant
mythologically that story because it's
got it exactly right if you
conceptualize the great father as power
hungry tyrant which is increasingly the
way we conceptualize our entire society
and we call it patriarchal
then why would you want to grow up to be
that
why why do you want to be that adult and
so if the mother is modeling her opinion
that that's what constitutes dad
that she's also modeling her opinion
that that's what constitutes future
mature son since he's going to be dad
yes exactly and then that boy hearing
that both let's say if he hears that
from the mother by the way this is true
father to mother also i mean
mouthing the part of the father of the
mother is really damaging to the child
because not only does the child is that
child half the genes of the other parent
but also the child can't bring it up to
either parent because if it brings it up
to the parent that made that complaint
um and it it loses that
the favoritism of that parent if it
brings it up to the other parent that
your dad said this or mom said this
about you that destabilizes the child's
um future even more so the child has a
terrible secret all the time
betrayal the child's in a state of
betrayal all the time no matter what
exactly and i've seen children used as
weapons continually in exactly that
manner it's it's it's appalling it's
it's appalling beyond comprehension
and then the fourth thing that's very
important is that the children that the
parents rather are in couples
communication counseling or relationship
counseling not just when there is an
emergency when there's an emergency
there's everything has to be made as a
quick decision and there's a tendency to
see the other parent's worst intent
whereas long-term counseling allows the
father and the mother to see
to have time to hear the mother or
father's best intent about what they're
doing and why they're doing it well so
at the bare minimum that means that the
couple gets together in an
administrative sense to sort out the
necessary details in the presence of a
relatively uh what would you say
interest-free commitment-free bias-free
third-party example it's really a
management ploy rather in some sense
rather than a counseling ploy per se or
at least you could parse it out in those
two ways
obviously once you have children with
someone you're married to them
permanently in some real sense and so
that has to be taken care of and a lot
of taking care of a marriage i do make
this point to some degree in in beyond
order when i talk about making space for
romance a fair bit of
marriage is administrative detail and
getting that down getting that right i
mean that all that does allow
you to see
some good will on the part of your
partner as well
yes absolutely
and you you brought up a moment ago to
go to the the the different development
developmental advantages that happen
when father and mother are both involved
and those developmental advantages
include
the father involvement
so after marriage or after divorce
father involvement
lack of father involvement is the single
biggest predictor of suicide
it is one of the biggest predictors of a
child not graduating from high school
dropping out of school
it's a very big predictor of a child
being having
being aggressive but not assertive and
last time when we did our last interview
together we talked about the whole
roughhousing dimension of things and i'm
not going to go through that again
because of the fact that people can go
to that other interview and see that but
there are about nine differences between
dad style parenting and mom style
parenting and a lot of those differences
moms are so good at say spotting uh sons
and daughters um you know gifts like say
sweetie you sing so nicely or you're
going to be a great actress or a
musician or whatever
you should try and do that and dads are
likely to affirm that but not so um
not so vociferously at first um but are
more likely to say some version of uh
well you know if you want to be a
gymnast you know if you want to be in
the olympics um you've got to practice
all the time and we'll yes we'll give
you the um
some tutoring or
will go out of our way to take you to
gymnastics practice but if you're not
really focused on if you're focused on
responding to tweets and and um going to
parties and doing other things you're
never going to become an olympic gymnast
so you have to make a trade-off and the
data's the data is much more likely to
hold uh enforce the boundaries around
that trade-off and require the child to
to focus and discipline um on focus and
um and have um postponed gratification
around what they say they want to do and
give up support for the child that the
child doesn't follow through with that
and only has a dream that they're not
willing to have the discipline to
function okay so that's okay so there's
a real hypothesis there
which i think is worth delving into
because one question obviously is well
why is it not good to be without a
father and is it not the case that
someone else may be two females for
example could
play the paternal role and obviously
that's true to some degree if we could
specify what the paternal role is
but you make a very specific case which
is quite an interesting one which is
that it's father's primarily who are
responsible for the instantiation of
delay of gratification now we should
point out that
among
psychologists who are leery of iq as the
best predictor of success in the long
run
the vast majority of those psychologists
whose opinion i do not agree with by the
way
is that the thing that predicts better
than iq is the capacity to delay
gratification and that seems to be
associated with trait conscientiousness
and trait conscientiousness which is
dutifulness and industriousness and
orderliness the ability to make and
maintain verbal contracts
conscientiousness is the best predictor
of long-term success outside of general
cognitive ability i would also say that
in cultures where families are more
likely to be intact and so we could say
southeast asian cultures for example
and point out that children from
southeast asian cultures do
disproportionately better in north
america than children of north american
parents the reason for that seems
two-fold one is more correlational
perhaps
in that those families are much more
likely to be intact and so to have
fathers but the second is is that the
advantage that is accrued to
those children seems to be
in the domain of conscientious striving
it's work ethic it's the ability to
delay gratification and so if it is the
case that
father involvement is a key predictor of
the capacity to delay gratification
then that's an absolutely crucial
issue and and
we need to know well is that true and we
also need to know if it's true why it's
true and perhaps it has something to do
with the relative disagreeability of of
fathers so
women are
more prone to negative emotion than men
and
they're more empathic and and and
compassionate and polite than men
men are more disagreeable and use
disagreeableness is the best predictor
by the way of criminal behavior from the
personality perspective even though it's
not a very good predictor but if you're
really really disagreeable that's one of
the things that can end that can land
you in jail because you don't take other
people into account you can be callous
and cruel and unkind
but just because something has its
pathologies in the extreme doesn't mean
it's not necessary
in moderation
and disagreeable people are
better at saying no and it's setting
boundaries and at being cruel to be kind
let's say well sure you're good at that
you want to do that but here's what it's
going to take and i'm going to draw
boundaries and i'm going to draw lines
and you think that's fathers and what
evidence do you have for that oh my
goodness just
for example one of the things i'll talk
about is um the
um the difference between boundary
setting and boundary enforcement and you
know dads and moms will both set
boundaries very similarly they'll both
say you can't have your ice cream until
you finish your peas and children will
test boundaries pretty much exactly the
same way they'll have as much as
possible before they get there
absolutely and they balance on that edge
and push because they want to find out
exactly where that border is my son
who's relatively disagreeable man he
pushed boundaries at every opportunity
when he was between two and four it was
really something to behold he was a
force of nature in
going right up to the line and pushing
on it just to see what was going to
happen you know and
and so
go ahead
yeah and then but the difference between
moms and dads is not these boundary
setting or the children's challenge but
rather the um the boundary enforcement
the child will be able to say to mom
some version of like
uh you know i had tough time in school
today i really felt now because i was
teased by this boy and he's the best
most popular boy or the most popular
girl in the school usually would be the
boy that would tease him and you know
and so mom is saying to herself you know
well what am i going to do here um am i
going to be get into a big argument over
a few peas when he's depressed that
would be insensitive and stupid so i'll
tell you what sweetie you know you can
have this many more peas and then you
can have your ice cream and then the boy
will see ah negotiating is or a girl
will see is negotiating is a possibility
here so from a position of weakness i
yes uh uh exactly i will have half that
many p's that mom you know put a set
aside and then mom is going again you
know all right now he at least tried
i'll give him the benefit of the doubt
um okay you can have the ice cream now
whereas dad is much more likely to go um
i'm sorry we have a deal here sweetie i
know you had a bad day in school uh but
you um but you need to finish the peas
the deal is before you get your ice
cream oh daddy you're so mean mommy
doesn't do that to me she went to me and
yeah
and and dad goes well you know you can
you can can continue to complain but
this is my rules now and if you continue
to complain there'll be no more ice
cream there'll be no ice cream even it's
a possibility tomorrow night
now we're forcing the child is getting
forced to have to pay attention to doing
what she or he needs to do finish the
peas before she or he gets the ice cream
what they want to have okay so let me
take what you said apart a little bit
from a personality perspective okay so
i'm gonna
hit it from three perspectives so the
first is i've always been entranced by
the disney movie pinocchio and pinocchio
is about the development of an
autonomous individual right someone
who's free from
having his strings pulled by others and
who isn't a wooden head but someone
who's alive and can think for himself
and
as pinocchio develops he faces a number
of temptations and one is to become an
actor which means to become a deceiver
or a player of parts rather than the
real thing but another is to become a
neurotic wreck who wants vacations so
he's tempted by pleasure island and the
way the fox and the cat tempt him is by
convincing him that he's ill
convincing him to capitalize on that and
convincing him that the respite for his
illness is a vacation from his permanent
vacation from his responsibility so his
the temptations are deceitful actor and
neurotic victim so it's a very
perspicacious film it's a remarkable
film but in any case now let's take that
apart a little bit so
i'll first make an observation for my
own marriage my wife is no pushover and
she's relatively low in agreeableness by
female standards
but what i observed in our relationship
was that
it was hard for her to discipline the
children especially when they were very
young and i think the reason for that
was partly temperament
because i think the feminine temperament
tilts towards compassion and nurturance
whereas the masculine temperament tilts
more towards um
uh
tough love
yeah yeah fine that's good thank you for
for filling in there yeah yeah it's
conditional it's if there's a
conditional element to it and then
judgmental element which you would no
love by the way but conditional approval
as part of total love
right good good clarification absolutely
right because the container is love yes
but but that can mean delay of
gratification right and there's a
cruelty and delay of gratification even
when you impose it on yourself it's a
it's a cruelty in the local sense
because it causes distress i mean right
now my son and daughter are teaching
their son who's only
slightly over one
no
and i told them how to do it so for
example he sits at our table
out in the backyard and he reaches
behind and he's tearing the plants out
of the green wall that's behind him and
so that's a no and i said
i encouraged him i said look take his
hand
hold it
firmly so that he can't move it say no
hold him until he stops struggling to to
undertake his goal directed activity
he'll probably cry
as soon as he stops resisting let go and
give him a pat say you do that 20 times
then when you say no he'll cry and stop
and then 20 times after that he'll just
stop he won't cry so 40 times and you've
taught him no which is an amazing thing
because then you can let him go free
because whenever you say no he'll just
stop and so you can facilitate his
freedom instead of having to be
a helicopter tyrant parent
who i've seen many of who is one step
behind their ambulatory two and a half
year old you know interfering with
absolutely everything he does because he
can't grasp a basic principle of
socialization in any case
no has some pain associated with it
because otherwise it wouldn't produce
tears and no is a very very hard thing
to learn and knows what the world
teaches not just what people teach in
any case
back to my wife
she spent the first year bonding with
the child and also learning how to
respond essentially especially in the
first six months to his or her every
whim because a crying infant demands
instant
recourse and the crying infant is always
right especially if they're under six
months of age but then when the kid
becomes ambulatory and starts to require
discipline the woman is required to
switch from this primarily
empathic role which is facilitated by
hormonal transformation post pregnancy
by the way
from this primarily nurturing role
to a role that is in some ways in the
local environment it's antithesis it's
very hard for women to do that and so my
observation has been that they they need
they require someone else to bolster
that element because it runs at counter
purposes to what they're required to do
in early infancy
and so okay so but so delay of
gratification we're going to focus on
that and an example illustrating what
you're saying this is hard data based
example that i talk about in the boy
crisis is the um is is bedtime so
what we know
when we look at bedtime set by mothers
and fathers is that moms will set
bedtimes earlier than dads will
dads will set bedtimes later but the
children end up when studied going to
bed earlier when they're with the dad
than they do with the mom
and so why is that what the dad will be
more likely to do is say some version of
like oh okay bedtime is nine o'clock and
um if you and whatever when you get all
your chores done when you get yourself
your br you brush your teeth you change
your clothes you've done your homework
etc um and i see your homework and it's
done well then any time that you have
between when you're finished when your
sister and brother are both finished uh
your homework etc that time you have to
play or do or ask me to do whatever i
want read your favorite story etc
with mom she's more likely to and so the
kids end up rushing to get through
the everything that they need to do uh
that is postponed gratification in order
to get what they want to have their this
story read to them some rough housing
before bedtime um and you know something
along those lines um and then with the
understanding that they will then uh
everything will be cut off at um at nine
o'clock the children with mom are more
likely to um
mom is as well is says you know bedtime
is this time it's 9 30 let's say and the
children
it gets to be 9 30 and one of the boys
or kids will say you know well i haven't
done my homework you know knowing that
mom will want the child to have done his
or her homework um be with um
rather than go to bed without having
homework be done and so that uh so mom
will say well all right you should have
done your homework before but uh we'll
allow you a little bit more time for
finish your homework off and so the boy
is able to orbit girl is able to
manipulate better more time than than
that 9 30 time um and
they open even or
say
up up even later
uh what what the dad makes clear to the
child is that if um if if he or she does
not if they use up all that time and
they haven't done up that doing the
homework and it's now nine o'clock your
bedtime um sorry but you are um you you
will not you just go to school and not
have your homework done that's your
responsibility to get that done by by
this point in time and so that um and so
that's one of the sort of dynamics that
happens that leads to children being
more likely to be focused on doing what
they need to do
and um and also children brought up by
mothers are more likely to be adhd if
they're brought up predominantly by
mothers 30 of children are adhd that
includes the average between boys and
girls boys are obviously more likely to
be adhd uh whereas with fathers brought
up predominantly by fathers only 15 are
likely to have adhd because you can see
from those examples that the the boy or
the girl the children are required to
focus on doing what they need to do get
that homework done get their teeth
brushed uh before they get what they
want to have
and the same we talked last time about
rough housing how uh the children the
children were um were
prevented from having more rough housing
fun if they pushed their sister or their
brother out of the way and they didn't
consider their the the needs of their
brother and sister
so
map back back to the
the
personality differences so women are
higher in negative emotion
and they're higher in trait
agreeableness and so
the way to manipulate someone who's high
in negative emotion is to
manifest negative emotion and to say
um here's a bunch of reasons why i'm not
doing so well and so i deserve a break
and that
so because of the sensitivity to
negative emotion the fact of the
negative emotion is more compelling
because it's more deeply felt and then
the agreeableness
means that there's a much higher
probability of being felt sorry for
and and you can see that in the positive
light when you're dealing with infants
because when they're in distress the
proper response is immediate
gratification of their desires
but that's not a good long-term strategy
which is i think likely why
well i don't exactly understand the
relationship with lower agreeableness
it's certainly the reason for the
emergence of conscientiousness which is
a cold virtue and which involves delay
of gratification now men are not more
conscientious than women they're more
industrious and industrious to some
slight degree and less orderly and those
two combined make conscientiousness but
the agreeableness difference is
definitely you know it's it's quite
pronounced and so you know partly what
you're arguing for from the perspective
of a personality psychologist is
the necessity for two parent families
really on temperamental grounds on and
really on biological grounds i mean
these things are mutable to some degree
but not easily not and
and the other thing that's quite
interesting is that and this is
something everyone should really listen
to is that
they're anti-mutable
given the way that our society is
proceeding so you might say well there
are these
personality differences between men and
women
higher neuroticism in women so that's
proclivity to negative emotion and
higher agreeableness
but if we made our societies equal
those personality differences would go
away and then we wouldn't require
bi-gendered
um parenting
but
what's happened is that if you go to the
scandinavian countries
where
the
attempts to equalize the social
landscape have gone the furthest
and in some sense had the most success
um there are notable exceptions so
if you rank order countries by the
egalitarian nature of their social
policies
now and that doesn't require that any of
them have perfectly egalitarian policies
it just requires that you admit that
some cultures are more egalitarian than
others in their
attempts and their practices and i think
only a fool wouldn't put the
scandinavian countries at the top of
that list
then you'd say well what that should
mean is that in scandinavia the
personality differences between men and
women are minimized and in authoritarian
countries they're maximized and exactly
the reverse is what happens
is if you
iron out the wrinkles in the social
landscape so that it's more egalitarian
men and women get more different with
regards to their interests people versus
things so women get more interested in
people and less interested in things and
less interested in the stem fields at
least in partial consequence science
technology engineering and mathematics
and
they get even more different than men in
terms of their neuroticism and their
agreeableness not less
and so
that argues
against easy social amelioration of this
necessity for
bi-gender two-parent households yes
yes the the children that seem to do the
best are ones that have
they're in intact families or as i
mentioned before
the children have about an equal amount
of time with both parents and that there
is a checks and balance parenting so a
child will come to the mother and say
can i climb the tree in the backyard and
mom will say well maybe in a few years
sweetie but not right now um you're too
young and you could really hurt yourself
and that child will ask the same thing
of a dad and the dad will be more likely
to say well yes i guess so but be
careful and then if the mother finds out
the child the father and the mother will
go oh wait a minute you know you're not
blah blah blah you're playing one
against the other here kid good work but
no
yes but well the kid will play one
against the other but but one of the
best responses to that is for the child
to be able to see the mother and father
negotiating right right absolutely and
saying you know well yes you can climb
the tree but you can't go this beyond
this branch this high and you can't you
know go on these branches and dad you uh
you need to be out there under the tree
so in case the child falls uh the other
child will will um be cushioned by your
fall and don't get preoccupied with the
cell phone in fact maybe give me the
cell phone while you're out there with a
with ginger or mary under the tree
right so they see the negotiation
between masculine and feminine taking
place why do you think that's so
important and you say there's research
supporting that specific proposition
it's a very specific proposition so
what's the research and it's both
specific and metaphorical specifically
we now know that children climbing trees
um
makes them worry about what risks are
worth taking what risks aren't that
fires um synapses that are outside of
their normal synapse firing uh
development and their uh and the data
that we have for that is that the is
that the iqs of children doing
risk-taking behaviors like climbing
trees increase as they do that risk
taking behavior and they increase their
psychomotor functioning
okay so there's this prop there's this
concept that a russian developmental
psychologist
came up with vygotsky called the zone of
proximal development and one of the
things he noted was that
i believe it was vygotsky who discovered
this it might not have been but it's the
same phenomenon so it doesn't really
matter so if you analyze the way that
parents talk to children who are
developing their language so infants who
are still learning to speak
the
adults don't speak to the infant in
terms that the infant can understand
precisely the adults speak to the infant
slightly ahead of its developmental
trajectory and vygotsky called that the
zone of proximal development which is
the key zone to be in if you're going to
learn so imagine and i make much of this
in my books that there's a domain that
you've already mastered
and so that when you operate in that
domain the things you want to happen
happen that's the domain of order
and then there's another domain where
all hell breaks loose and you don't know
what to do and that's the domain of
chaos but there's an intermediary where
you're expanding your zone of competence
through exploration
and that's really where consciousness
operates and
that's that's where we learn and so
risk-taking behavior isn't exactly
risk-taking behavior it's it's
embeddedness in the zone of proximal
development i'll give you an example so
it's germaine to your example
so
when my kids were little i bought this
old wrecked um
wooden playset
monkey bars and and swings it was
dilapidated but i took it home and
sanded it down and repainted it and you
know gave it about five or six more
years of life
and uh
my daughter who was about
two and a half at the time
would go out there on that monkey bar
and so it was a ladder going up about
six feet which is a pretty decent ladder
for for a little two and a half year old
you know and so we were inclined to
watch her
and she would stand on the first rung
and then move her foot a quarter of the
way up towards it and then half a way up
towards it and then three quarters of
the way up towards it and then she'd put
her foot on the rung and then she'd do
the same with her next foot staying in
that zone of proximal development can i
move a quarter a step can i move half a
step can i move three quarters of a step
and we'd watch her do that and doing
that she pinned all those movements
together and mastered climbing up the
monkey bar and it was much to our
satisfaction to watch her because she
was taking she wasn't taking a risk
exactly she was pushing herself out into
the zone of proximal development and and
engaging in this mastery behavior so you
could say in some sense and i believe
this to be the case that the masculine
spirit encourages and facilitates the
transformation so if the if the feminine
is
is concentrating on who the child is now
and what that child now needs the
masculine is concentrating on how that
child can move to the next developmental
stage and pushing that along is that is
that a reasonable presumption a yes and
b here's an example that also that the
coordinates
connects perfectly with that uh the data
shows that dads are more likely for
example uh to use words that the child
does not yet understand or does not
understand at that time
and um and the mom is oftentimes looking
at saying well you know why are you
saying that you know the child doesn't
understand what you mean and the dad's
conscious or unconscious sort of feeling
is i want to plant seeds and after the
child hears this in different contexts
um she or he will begin to sort of
understand what that word is and what
that means and moms feel it's just moms
are more likely to feel uh that's just
so insensitive
being in this zone of proximal
development like
if
i brought that into the conversation
because you talked about risk-taking and
so what you could say is that as you
push the boundaries of the zone of
proximal development you enter the
domain of risk
and so then the question would be what
personality elements
are capable of tolerating the
transformation of the zone of proximal
development into the zone of risk and
the answer to that would be lower
neuroticism and lower agreeableness
because lower neuroticism would mean you
wouldn't worry as much
so the magnitude of the perceived risk
would be less and lower agreeableness
would mean well even if there is some
risk you don't care as much it's like
it's okay now it's not like you don't
care about the risk exactly although it
is that in some felt sense but the
reason for that is that well there's
another judgment which is well the risk
is worth taking because there's more
than one risk at play here there's the
proximal risk that you engage in when
you push yourself but there's the distal
risk that you engage in when you don't
push yourself
yes you're right on target there now and
this is why so many of the differences
between male and female style parenting
are so important
to understand and what one of those that
sort of connects to what you're saying
is that the differences that moms and
dads tend to to get into about dad's
teasing children
um and which feels to many moms like it
often results in the child crying when
the teasing first starts
but it begins to teach the child a whole
series of skill sets um you know
what's what tones of voice are teasing
or playfulness and it's like rough
housing it has
teasing is an abstraction of rough
housing exactly precisely um you know
what i what eye contact is being playful
what eye contact is serious uh what what
body language what i'm exaggerating now
um you get off the bed because if you
don't get off the bed daddy will always
be
make it make life hard for you you know
how bad daddy is um and the you know the
child starts laughing
maybe after a while maybe one time
this going like that that the child goes
oh my goodness is scared and so then
after a while the child learns that oh
that's daddy having fun that's us having
fun and they begin to distinguish
between um
make sure you get off the bed as fun
versus make sure you get off the bed as
you know something that is right well
they also learn to distinguish between
what's mean and what's funny you know i
mean when i was watching my children
especially with regards to their sibling
rivalry which is likely to emerge in
children who are less than three years
apart in their birth order and and sort
of in proportion to the closeness of
their of their birth
so if you want to minimize childhood
sibling rivalry you space the children
out three years we don't know what that
does to their relationship across time
but we know it minimizes sibling rivalry
in any case i wanted them always to stay
on the funny side of teasing because
teasing can easily turn into torture and
so they had to learn these extremely
fine gradations of humor and and and to
do that they had to play on the edge and
the question is how necessary is it to
have the capacity to allow your children
to play on the edge and fathers have
that by temperament more than mothers do
now but you you know you pointed out
something really interesting
you didn't exactly make the claim that
the father was necessary you made a more
subtle claim which was that the dialogue
between the father's
higher risk tolerance and the mother's
lower risk tolerance is necessary and
that takes place that can take place
within an intact marriage but you also
said it can take place
in an in a marriage that's been broken
apart as long as the couple's commit to
a long-term communication strategy that
a super long-term supervised
communication strategy
so it's the dialogue maybe that's really
the issue here it's the interplay
between masculine feminine
is that the key thing rather than the
presence of both is because you can
imagine a man and a woman in a household
who don't communicate ever about
anything and i can't imagine that that's
going to be an optimal environment for a
child despite the fact that both parents
are nominally there yes yes absolutely
the the children do well when both
parents are involved
about equally and that's because of a
lot of subtle things here one for
example is hangout time and particularly
boys if you ask them like how is soccer
today uh the boy will say okay
and um but with hangout time and no not
much more well what else happened what
happened at soccer today nothing much
um you know and then but if the father
has hang out time let's say in a divorce
situation with the child uh the child is
likely maybe they're
ones doing homework the other was doing
they're a different type of work and
they end up in the kitchen together and
they're looking through the thing and
then the boy will say
dad you know daddy i i don't get it if
you if you're playing soccer and you're
doing really well and i was goalie last
week and this week i wasn't goalie but i
thought i did really well
and the coach even said i did really
well but now he put he put in jimmy for
goalie goalie instead of me
what's that about um and that's when
children with hangouts with hangout time
both boys and girls tend to to do much
better than they do when they just are
asked a quick question for a
conversation for daughters they need
time for the questions to bubble up
of their own accord exactly or some
little thing reminds them of something
you know if you ask a child how are you
doing oftentimes they'll say fine but if
you said you know if you ask them
something specific how did you like
having the ice cream taken away from you
by by somebody at school then they'll
have a response to that um so when
something triggers something that is
very specific the child will tend to
sort of open up and um on his or her own
terms and interestingly i said hang out
time was very important for boys uh
psychologically the uh some researchers
at the university of california irvine
said it's the single greatest predictor
of psychological security in girls
hangout time with that and hangout time
with moms and dads has a different
dimension to it the children know that
if they if they say say a problem to mom
she's more likely to be reassuring i'm
sure that you know i'm sure they really
wanted you to do really well he was
probably just giving the other the other
the other um
person a chance because uh in order for
them to feel good about themselves like
you did when you play goalie whereas the
child is usually likely to know that the
dad is more likely to say well you know
what did you do uh that maybe was not um
so good as a goalie uh what do you think
you can do that's different with it with
the uh with the coach next time did you
ask the coach directly why she or he
took you away from being goalie and so
um that's more of a problem-solving
approach or a problem and you think
that's associated with the positive
developmental consequence for iq
i think it is
it's not that lower iq farthers tend to
get divorced more often by any chance is
it well we well we do know that that
mothers are who are well educated are
far more likely about 90 of divorces um
come from mothers are initiated um by
the plaintiff is the mother
and when the other is well educated she
has other sources of income other
sources of education and um and security
and she also knows um obviously that in
the family courts
she's far more likely to have the
children and the father is far less like
you know she's more likely to have the
right to the children he's more likely
to have to fight for the children um and
um and so there's all sorts of dynamics
going on there but i think the most
important thing here to understand is
that
like we were talking a bit before about
teasing there are so many um
developmental um
advantages to a lot of the things that
dads do
but i want to really make it clear that
dads don't say to moms things like i'd
like to roughhouse with the children
because it will increase the children's
empathy i'd like to roughhouse with the
children because it will increase their
social skills i'd like to tease with the
social abilities to to have to right god
who could stand to be married to someone
who did that yes
and the result of that is that you know
moms can't hear what dads don't say and
it's one of the so one of the reasons
why the communication
about
what is and dad's need to take
responsibility for reading about uh what
there is uh that we do that's
differently and what the outcomes are um
of the things that we do differently so
i've never heard of a father say to a
mother you know the teasing that i do
um with with with our daughter or our
son you know when we go into when kids
go into the workplace and they haven't
learned how to be uh they haven't
learned teasing uh they feel that
teasing is sort of an insult
right they're touchy they're touchy and
they can't take a joke with a sense of
humor
we had very explicit discussions about
such things in my household
so i mean i wanted the kids to be
inoculated against casual
insult
you have to take that with a sense of
humor or or it just mounts i've seen
people who can't
respond to that initial testing you know
and it's partly what people do to see if
you're socialized
you see because people want to socialize
with people who are about as socialized
as them and so what they'll do first is
throw out some teasing and see what
happens and if it evokes a playful
response then they know that the person
that they're dealing with can be relied
on to play and has been reasonably
socialized you're hitting the nail right
on the head
the commerce of masculinity is
the the trading of which covered put
downs
and men
learn as they grow up that i think
probably the reason that that happens is
because um men learn that if you can
handle if you can handle criticism
you're not going to be successful and if
you're not going to be successful you're
also unpredictable because it means that
if something small and upsetting comes
along you're going to get big and upset
and that isn't what you want you don't
want someone who's going to get upset
about something small
it's it's too dangerous in the crisis
absolutely and so from a male point of
view from most men's point of view um
the feeling is if you can't be teased
you can't be trusted
right right exactly you can't be really
respected and here's the type of
problems that that creates in the
workplace so if you're if you're a dad
talking here
to the mom about teasing children help
her see how this evolves into the
workplace so in the workplace
a girl a woman oftentimes may get teased
and she will interpret that teasing like
you know um did you i see you see you
have a new dress on that you uh did you
get that to flirt with the boss or do
you have you know you're dressed um you
must have dressed in the dark last night
um something like that that's something
if you say it to a guy they come back at
you with some funny um counter
point like you know well that would be
typical for a short man to say uh a
version of that and and and the and the
men with each other
when they can tease each other like that
and play with each other
that means that they're beginning to
trust that man and move them into their
into their league of people they can
respect and trust
whereas if the woman hears something
like that comment she might feel it's a
it's a sense it means that she's being
discriminated against in the workplace
so she takes that perspective and says
now that would be a particularly true i
suspect if she didn't have a lot of
masculine presence in her life exactly
and she know that girls who don't have
brothers are much more likely to be
raped
i
i didn't know that that's interesting
and i do believe that um and because a
lot of the and this does confirm a
number of things that i've heard of
people who are experts in that area and
that's very very deeply sad and
particularly what's what's reinforcing
this you were talking about how
things in today's culture sort of
reinforce this so let's say this girl
this woman is new to work and there
she's being tested out by being teased
and she feels really insulted and she
interprets the teasing as discrimination
against her as opposed to interpreting
the teasing as an attempt to include her
uh to include her yeah exactly nicely so
she goes to hr it's an invitation to
play
it's an invitation to play it's an
indication if you're skilled at it right
i mean that's i mean a tease can go too
far and then it's insulting but but the
really good tease is right on the edge
right and then that's also
it's also a compliment to the person
who's designed to receive it because
you're
facing them with the proposition that
they can tolerate a comment they're
sophisticated enough to know when a
comment is right on the edge and they're
resilient enough to tolerate it and
respond in kind so it's an it's a
complement of the highest order to push
like that it is so important that you
said that that's exactly right that's
exactly what teasing does test for and
that's exactly what men who tease each
other are testing for to see if the if
the playfulness could be met with
playfulness it can be better with even a
greater challenge that requires them to
participate in the process but
institutionally today we've taken and
you think part of that's crucial to iq
development
i do think that's interesting because i
mean t that teasing banter is a form of
of of of what dynamic wit it's like a
dance i mean some cultures have really
perfected that you get there's
subcultures in england particularly
where that's
elevated to an art form and and you see
that in places like newfoundland and
canada as well and in alberta as well i
would say in the rural areas in
particular yes absolutely and so
now what we've done is institutionalized
this
teasing as a problem so the woman
upset that she's being discriminated
against goes to hr and says i was
discriminated against what he said to me
right thus failing a test
in in a more profound way because one of
the things you do when you're in
elementary school in junior high school
in high school for that matter and then
in the workplaces tease someone and see
if they run off to find a figure of
authority or whether they can deal with
it themselves
because you assume that if they have to
run off and find a figure of authority
that they're not mature enough to solve
their own problems that's exactly right
and so what we so the woman reports it
to hr and hr really is no longer hr it
really should be called h-e-r uh because
it focuses almost always a complaint by
the woman about usually a man and the do
you know what the stats are in
proportion of workplace complaints that
are brought forth by women compared to
men i know the ocr
stats of the office of civil rights
stats about complaining is about i think
it was
there's a fellow named joseph who's done
the research on that and i think he said
it was like 19 to one 19 complaints by
women about men for age one complaint by
men about a woman
right and that's funny because you know
the men probably generate the grounds
for complaints more often being more
disagreeable and the women are more
sensitive to the uh negative
consequences being less emotionally
stable more more neurotic so it's
that's a place where men and women don't
feed back so well to one another you
know and it's unfortunate but that that
well i have wondered you know if men and
women can inhabit the same workplace
over time we don't know that i mean i've
been called reprehensible for even
bringing that up as an issue but it's
not like we know we haven't the data
aren't in we've only been working
together in some sense for 50 years and
there's plenty of evidence for sex
segregation it seems to be the the norm
rather than the exception that you know
once
a gender a sex starts to dominate a
field that that dominance becomes more
and more predominant until it becomes
almost total you see that with
engineering you see it with nursing
those are extreme cases but it certainly
does happen well they're not as extreme
as bricklaying which is like all men but
women have you know women haven't moved
into the bricklaying domain so we don't
know what would happen if they did they
won't but so we won't know but you know
now and this the the
the challenge here is really enormous
because the um
in the sexual area um it's very rare
that a woman is interested in dating
somebody at work who is earning less uh
than she is um and um is not doesn't
have his high status and usu the great
majority of women that i've seen that
have uh that were single when they
entered the workplace and then married
somebody a significant percentage of
them have married somebody in the
workplace but the great majority of that
significant percentage have married
somebody at least at their level and
usually above them at work yeah it's
hypergamy right and it characterizes
women with regard to um potential for
generous earning essentially and
unsurprisingly i think it's an attempt
to
balance the economic
scales because women take the brunt of
pregnancy and
and
the brunt of the first year of of child
rearing i would say as well so and they
make themselves vulnerable as a
consequence so they need to
redress that
inequality
and that's how they do it and
but there are consequences to that that
are very severe in the socioeconomic and
the social spheres
absolutely and then when the woman when
a man above her
does take
interest in her and and it's explicit
about it um you know it's it it can
either result in courtship or a law
court and so the courtship of one form
or the other yes or and
allah yes one courtship of one one form
or the other and so it's a really uh
it's it's and and what the biggest
problem with that's happened in the last
15 20 years especially since hashtag me
too
um is that um
i have not yet spoken to a single
corporate ceo
who has not said some version of the
following to me you know warren i used
to love mentoring women
but i have a wife and i have children
there's no way shape or form that i will
mentor a woman today
right
there
right well it was increasingly insistent
upon in in my workplace at the
university that if i ever had a female
in the room with me that the door be
open
i mean and as soon as that's the rule
you're you're done you have to start
rethinking everything can you travel
with your graduate students
can you be in the same hotel etc etc etc
as soon as you have to start thinking
about those things
that means the risk has become so great
that you're much less likely to engage
in such activity
and mentoring is a very intimate
relationship so it's it's
it is it it's oftentimes does inc i mean
many men
are particularly inspired to mentor to a
woman who's younger that that is
attractive and many younger attractive
women are uh increase their
um their caring about and their love for
a man who is who is
who they see as a result of his
mentoring
yeah well you know across cultures women
prefer men who are about four years
older there's some variation and that
actually is one of the things that is
moderated in the scandinavian culture so
that age gap is less rather than more in
the scandinavian cultures but that goes
along with the genuine general tendency
to to hypergamy which is preference for
a mate who's at or above
you in the social hierarchy yes or the
socioeconomic hierarchy it's really the
social hierarchy though
which create enormous problems in
different cultures like in china
when we do analyses of the dating the
most popular dating site in china
you see that um
women want a
very high percentage of women i think
it's in the 92 to 93 percent title
approximately of women uh want men who
own homes and own cars
but of the people on the dating sites
who are males only a very small
percentage of them own homes and cars
right well and we should also point out
that women aren't actually going for the
home or the car they're going for the
ability to produce the home in the car
of course right they're using them as
secondary markers for competit for
competence essentially but and then they
you know you cite an interesting stat
here too which which i thought was worth
talking about
um
day on on who should pay the bill on the
first date um
72 of women
think that a man should pay the full
bill
on the first date now remember they've
already selected this man and what that
means is that he's likely to be at or
above them in the socioeconomic
hierarchy and perhaps slightly older so
you know in some sense they can afford
he can afford to pay better than she can
but in any case 82 percent of men think
the same
and so men are playing the hypergamy
game even more uh intensely than women
are at least with regards to that
particular statistic
so
and this gets into the psychology of the
pay gap because many women feel okay
about that because they feel like okay
men earn more than i do for the same
work um when when would be
and in fact that is not really accurate
here is what is accurate
fathers earn more than moms do the pay
gap is not men women the pay gap is
dads versus moms and when dads become
dads
they're far more likely to give up the
things that they love to do that pay
less
and do the things that they like to do a
lot less um you know quit that musician
gig that paid much less and do something
responsible quote-unquote like selling
product y um yeah that's also in line
with the data that show that you know
most
most young men many many young men abuse
alcohol
most of them stop when around 27 but
that's also when they get married and so
they they stop engaging in primary
gratification and that's another example
of that delay of gratification as far as
i'm concerned that ability or
willingness to sacrifice
yes and it's also part of your your
whole rule about the you know it's
important to have stable structures but
it's also important to have flexibility
and structures in part of you know it's
so funny that we it's so rare that we
can have a real conversation about this
because let's say that the pay gap well
you know it's certainly not obvious
what degree the pay gap is caused by
female hypergamy
right if men demanded of their dating
partners that they earned more
than they do my guess is that there'd be
a pay gap in favor of women
because men are incentivized to earn
more because if they don't
that the consequence is on the in the
sexual market but it's not the sexual
it's the um intimate interpersonal
market right to not be cynical about it
because it's it's not all short-term
mating that people are motivated by
quite the contrary well they're
motivated to take the dangerous is more
dangerous less desirable farther away
from from home and family and interest
for that matter jobs because the
payoff is disproportionately large for
men who do so and you see that you know
you see and it's exaggerated at the
upper end of the distribution as well
which is what you pointed out with
regards to the dating sites you know
like 70 of men are rated as below the
50th percentile in attractiveness by
women and so
not only are there
rewards for earning more there are
disproportionate awards for men for
earning more and that goes along with
the proposition that we put forward at
the beginning of this conversation i
think that was recorded as well that
you know the most admired people are men
but the least admired people are men as
well and there's a lot more least
admired men than there are most admired
men and that's true in in brutal force
on the dating scene
on the websites
absolutely
and and as i said part of the reason
that this is sort of all justified is
because you know after all men have
privilege and you know and men are you
know are the
and the pay gap is really a reflection
of the fact that you know men um do less
work and earn the same or um and yes
which is complete bloody nonsense that's
just not true that's that there is a gap
but the the reason for the gap is very
very complex and involves many factors
including the ones we discussed here
which you take apart so nicely in your
book why men earn more
i think you have 13 reasons that men
earn more you know that's quite a few
reasons and privilege isn't one of them
it's actually 25 differences between the
choices that men tend to make and the
choices that women tend to make
25 differences are things that do lead
to men earning more money um but could
you list a few of those now because it's
such an interesting it's such an
interesting topic men are more likely to
take hazardous jobs they're more likely
to take jobs like logging or trucking
uh they're more likely to take jobs that
um that require them to work weekends or
evenings
they're more likely to take jobs that um
that have very little people contact
like being an engineer and but most men
do like people contact
but many of the jobs with
less people contact like being an
engineer mathematician tend to pay less
um the
men are more likely to
um
let's see
uh uh work a longer a longer hours yeah
so the u.s bureau of labor statistics um
when you when you hear somebody works
full-time that only means that they work
35 hours a week or more not 40 hours a
week is what you usually think of as
full-time well the average person who
works 44 hours per week makes twice the
money as somebody who works 35 hours a
week it's twice i see well i remember
one of your stats which was i think 10
more working hours is 20 more income
something like that but that's a much
more dramatic stat statistic 44 hours is
twice as valuable as 35 hours yes
and men are much more likely to work
that 44 hours or more per week right and
thus not be there for their children as
is exposed in family court exactly and
that and that of course is very
fascinating it's what i call the
father's catch-22 that that dads learn
to love the family by having to be away
from the love of their family but when
the pew research center
asked dads who were full-time working
dads
uh would you prefer to remain full-time
working or if you had the option of
leaving your job full-time and being
full-time with the children which would
you um prefer
49 of dads said who worked full-time so
these are not sort of loser dads or
dad's not inclined to work 49 of dads
who worked full-time said that they
would prefer to be home with their
children full time
uh and maybe work a little bit or not
outside of the home
and um and yet that uh that question has
never
almost never even asked of dads usually
when middle and upper middle class
people
are married and they have children
the mom generates three options option
one is to work full-time option two is
to be full-time with the children option
three is to do some combination of both
and dads you know they have three
options too option one is to work
full-time option two is to work
full-time and option three is to work
full-time or more accurately um if
they're a working-class person to work
two jobs if they're
more of a white-collar worker um they'll
tend to sort of work more hours at the
job that they're doing and so that type
of uh these types of differences are not
seen and the easiest way to see these is
that um women who have never been
married and never had children
they earn 117
of what men who have never been married
and never had children earn
it's only when men
have get married and have children that
they begin to do what you were talking
about before and start taking on a a
commitment a new responsibility okay so
your claim your claim it's no wonder
you're so popular
your claim is essentially that men don't
earn more because of privilege they earn
more because they take responsibility
not not that women don't i'm not saying
that but i'm not saying that they're
taking responsibility in a different way
because they're focused on the children
and maybe they sacrifice their career
for that and maybe that's what they want
to do but it doesn't matter they're
still doing it but
the reason that men earn more is because
they're earning more for the people they
love
even yes even politically um liberal
people who normally believe in minimal
sex roles
when it comes to the children being born
the mothers are much more likely to sort
of even if they're working full-time
remember we said full-time is 35 hours a
week they're much more likely to go from
maybe working 45 45 hours a week before
to doing a few things that are different
one is to working uh not only fewer
hours but finding a job that is closer
to home so they can be more flexible and
we see this the best way i think to
understand the difference in the pay gap
is to look at what happens with
women who own their own businesses
versus men who own their own businesses
so take two groups that are quite equal
they both have mbas
um and they um
and so they're committed obviously to
work the rochester institute of
technology studied both groups of men
and women with both mbas who owned their
own business
women earned only 49
of what men earned
and so the the assumption when they
started this was wow women who own their
own business that will you know they
don't have the discrimination of um you
know the discriminating male uh bosses
and so therefore they'll be valued more
they'll probably earn as much or more
than
their male counterparts and the answer
was no so the rochester institute of
technology then
investigated that further and they asked
women and men uh which is the most
important values for you in owning your
own business uh 70 72 of the men said
the most important value for me was a
greater income only 29 of women said it
was greater income the women wanted
more time they wanted time they wanted
stability um and they wanted safety also
um men were much less concerned about
safety than uh women were which is why
you know all you all of your hats why
uber drivers make more when they're men
at least in part yeah
and higher risk tolerance yes and i mean
if you know let's say you don't have a
college education or even you've dropped
out of high school and so if you're
you might um get a job as a as a garbage
collector you have to get up early in
the morning
it's dirty it's hazardous
and yet a female who is has an art
degree a master's degree in art
may earn less than that garbage
collector um and partially it's because
you know people tend to need their
garbage picked up more than they need a
new piece of art and so um these are so
many of the 25 differences that are
um between men and women but the good
news about this how did we get to an
estate warrant where
the
given
25 differences is a lot of differences
and it doesn't make for a very big
difference in pay by the way
um even the most
radical
proponents of the unequal pay theory are
struggling to come up with a figure that
exceeds 15 percent
so 25 differences amounting to 15 isn't
that much of a difference
um
but
you know if the data are so clear that
it's
fathers who are driving this and it's
relatively self-evident i would say if
it was single guys that was driving this
you could make a case that was for
selfish um pleasure seeking purposes
right and that would fit pretty nicely
into the privileged narrative right
power hungry greedy selfish
short-sighted men with privilege make
more money it's like well wait a minute
it's father's oh so why are they doing
that
well and never married women who have
never had children
earn 117
of what never married men who have never
had children earn
never married women who have never had
children they are more likely to plan
for their careers and they do earn more
and what's most astonishing is that
never married women who have never had
children have earned more than never
married men who have never had children
since the 1970s
just now it's 117 percent more and so
exactly what you said is true um it is
not um
never married women with with never who
have never had children they tend to
focus on their careers whereas different
married men who have never had children
they're much more likely to be able to
do something like music or art or and
and and gay men historically have often
been very successful in art because
they've been usually never married men
who have never had children and they've
been able to afford to do things that
were less likely and dependable to
produce money oh i've never heard that
explanation before that's
that's that's quite an explanation
so so let's delve into that a little bit
more deeply the the time and money issue
so
when women
rank order their preferences when they
have options so these are the middle
class upper middle class women you
talked about they're going to go for
more time
and i presume that they want more time
to spend that with their kids
that's been my observation
that's the number one thing
okay
and then men are making more money
instead but it's farthers that are
making more money so they're making more
money for what reason is it like exactly
is it for their kids is it for their
wife and kids is it so that their wife
maintains her attractive
her attraction to the man because that's
a that's a big issue that no one ever
talks about right i mean
within marriages i've seen this many
times
within marriages if the male takes a
status hit
he also takes a
attractiveness hit and it's a severe hit
i've seen this many many times and no
one will ever talk about it but it's
definitely the case here's the best way
to understand that bridge the man takes
a status hit
he starts losing respect for himself his
wife starts losing a little bit of
respect for him wondering whether or not
that this is going to result in a job
down the line or whether some promise or
belief that he has is going to
manifest
if she's really the man he thought she
was she thought he was
he feels that less respect and a woman
is and i think every woman will agree
with this it's almost impossible for a
woman to love a man she doesn't respect
and there's
this i think it's that the opposite is
true too but maybe the grounds for
respect differ the grounds for
respectively and also
a man
there's more flexibility with a man on
the respect issue there may not be more
flexibility in terms of first falling in
love on the beauty issue women have
their burden that they have to
that they have to live up to as well
but the but on the respect issue um it's
very challenging for if a woman begins
to lose respect she begins to lose love
and men sense this and therefore they
oftentimes brag or boast or uh or you
know
overstate their potential um in order to
be able to make themselves attractive
and
we see this in so many levels on the
lowest lane level
lois lane you know she had no interest
in clark kent but she fell in love with
superman and once she fell in love with
superman she wanted superman to be able
to cry and express emotions but the man
who did
cry and express emotions and feelings
insensitive clark kent she has zero
interest in
um you know women are oftentimes say i'm
opposed to war um but look at the she's
much more likely to fall in love with
the officer and a gentleman than she is
the private and the pacifist um and you
know and they
we talk about this even in high school
most everybody's gone to high school and
most high schools have football games
and um and the and the women are the
cheerleaders go first and ten do it
again for the guy that scores the
touchdown um or cat uh either by
throwing the pass or catching the pass
and if the guy feels like it's too
dangerous for him to play football and
he leaves the football team it's very
rare that the
the cheerleader says you know i noticed
how well how good your listening skills
were when you're in the huddle and how
warm and tender you are i want to
continue cheering for you no she tends
to cheer for his replaceable part
another number seven um risking his life
um uh with a concussion or a spinal cord
injury and now this is non this is
non-trivial um behavior i mean because
you look at
the the football team i've been writing
about that recently the football example
is particularly interesting especially
because it's such a trope in american
especially in american popular culture
everybody knows the story right um
but what's so interesting too is the men
will
on the team will elevate their best
player to the highest position of status
despite the fact that they all take a
hit in terms of sexual attractiveness by
doing so i mean maybe you know being on
a winning team elevates uh a rising tide
boats well definitely but but it's still
the case that they'll take a uh relative
hit within the confines of the team to
elect the man to the position where he's
most likely to receive the favors of
attraction from the most valuable the
most desired women yes exactly so
i mean trying to puzzle out the role of
sexual selection thinking that through
because
men men select the women that men select
the men that women select
it's very very interesting to watch that
happen
and
yeah absolutely and you'll see this you
know both sexes figure out very
carefully when people say well men are
more competitive than women that's not
really true um both sexes are very
competitive uh for getting having the
goodies uh that lead them to be have the
greatest amount of choice uh so women
will compete with other women about how
they dress what their dresses look like
if a woman is at a party
and she's interested in one or two of
the guys at that party and a really
attractive woman comes through the door
uh she will assess what her chances are
and what you know what um how she should
position herself to make sure she gets
the contact with the man that she really
wants to make contact with and the men
will do the same type of thing around um
you know the things that they feel will
lead a woman to be
attracted to them this also makes it
very it's very
difficult for men to figure out this is
another reason why i question the
long-term viability of
not not that i truly question it but
these questions arise in my mind the
long-term viability of mixed sex
workplaces
the rules for competing with other men
are pretty clear
the rules for competing with women are
not clear at all yes
because if you're a loser you're still a
loser but if you're a winner you're just
so easily a bully
so it isn't obvious what
what how men can negotiate that well
they have to negotiate it through
negotiation that's the only possible
outcome but it definitely makes things
much much more complex and it's it's
also
it's complex at least in part because as
you just pointed out within the sexes
the competition is about different
things
so
or sorry between the sexes no no within
the sexes the competition is about
different things so when a woman
competes with a status with st with a
man for status she's competing for male
status not female status
and so
what to make of that well why that would
be rewarding to her isn't that obvious
and i think that's part of the reason
why so many women bail out of high
pressure situations jobs when they hit
their 30s i mean part of it is that they
would rather be with their family and
for obvious reasons but the the the
other unspoken elephant in the room is
always well
why would it be particularly rewarding
for a woman to attain status in the
masculine hierarchy what what benefit
does that confer on her well more income
that's one of them but
that confers no attractiveness advantage
whereas for men it accrues a tremendous
attractiveness advantage
it's definitely disproportionate male
versus female i would say though that
if tooth if a woman is if a man has a
choice between two women and they're
both equally attractive and their
personalities are pretty much the same
etc and one is more successful than the
other the man is likely to be more
attracted to the more successful woman
but he's also likely to be afraid of
rejection right yeah successfully yes
definitely definitely feel that that
more successful woman will have more
options uh she will have more options
she will have more and she'll have
higher demands as well because she's
going to want to make that's the real
issue is that's where the rejection
issue comes in it's not even necessarily
that she has more options it's that
because she's more successful her
criteria for what constitutes acceptable
are going to be elevated they may even
be elevated to the point of
impossibility for her exactly and and
the real fear that the man has is the
fear of being rejected
yes definitely and i i think that that
well i've made light of that
by teasing my my class
my my my students you know i said well
what's the what's the what's the joke
well you're you're perfectly suitable as
a
companion but in no way should your
genetic material be allowed to propagate
itself into the next generation
right that's that's the core of
rejection and it's no it's it's it cuts
to the bone
it cuts to the bone and i i i it isn't
obvious that that
that that's sufficiently understood how
terrified men are of female rejection
well that's part of the turning to
pornography i would say
and the advantage of dating sites like
tinder because the rejection is taken
out of the game essentially or it's
hidden masked tinder is a is a
revolutionary technology because it
alters the
reward structure reward and punishment
structure in dating i mean
it's a it's incendiary
and named properly
pornography is basically access to a
variety of attractive women
without fear of rejection
at a price you can afford
and right and with with the with the
commensurate responsibility
except to yourself
right but that's easily foregone in the
moment and the challenge of it is that
the more
so boys who are usually doing less young
men who are doing less well in school
who are not the who are not the football
players that are getting the 15
different women coming up to them and
risking rejection um who are not the
student body presidents who are not
standing out in one way or the other or
not getting great grades not part of the
honor society etc uh the the
non-standout men the ones that are
oftentimes
dad deprived uh that have minimal
postponed gratification and so on and
they tend to do badly in school or drop
out of school uh those boys feel like
losers and they they know that women
tend to not date losers they tend to
date winners and um and they end up in
the unemployed and what women are
looking for um forgot uh and and much
more likely to be in their families um
live with their families um 66 percent
more likely oh yes that's another
statistic
young men between 25 and 31 are 66
percent more likely than young women to
be living with their parents yes and
more young men are living with a parent
than with a partner
yes and they and you don't find women um
looking um in their
looking for men that are living in their
parents basement or looking for no well
that's just a joke which is why you you
know you could insert it there as a
cliche everyone understands exactly what
that means it means failure to launch it
means peter pan right it's a joke
and
and those women are therefore more like
those guys rather are much more likely
to turn to pornography because um they
sense they're being rejected by women um
and then they turn to this beautiful
woman that they can be turned on by the
challenge with pornography is that the
more you get into it the more you tend
to be stimulated by more and more risky
things and more and more salacious
things or you know or things that are
yeah well that's because novelty
enhances enhances pleasure
so that's the addictive element of it
precisely and then the female who is
interested in that guy um and does come
over to you know to be with him
physically
she often feels like this guy is like
you know more interested in something
that happened in the pornographic um
things that he's been watching she feels
like an object like and because she is
being treated like an object well and
also those are the men who aren't going
to be particularly sophisticated in
their their treatment of women because
how could they be they have no
experience precisely and so the the
pornography ends up haunting them on
multiple levels um and and leads them to
often turn back to pornography to avoid
continuing rejection and only convinces
them that a real-life woman isn't
somebody that he would uh fail on one
level or another with and so it's a
really
um have you ever seen robert crumb's
representations of bird-headed women no
you don't have it robert crum is an
underground cartoonist and he was the
feature of a documentary which you
should you and everybody else who's
listening to this should definitely
watch huh it's it's absolutely it's the
best documentary i've ever seen about
anything ever it's and he he
draws these women they're pr he was a
loser in high school by his own
admission by every single category you
could possibly generate and so it's a
study in
loser
psychology but it's really complex
because he was a loser
who was extremely intelligent and
unbelievably creative and who had two
brothers who were probably more
intelligent more creative than him but
although also more psychopathological
and then he became successful he was one
of the establishers of
of underground cartooning back in the in
the 1960s and and and and spawned
arguably even graphic novel you know i
mean he's a major player in that in that
niche and
the documentary is a brilliant analysis
of the relationship between failure and
success and sexual failure and sexual
success because in one more memorable
scene he talks about
he drew this card when he was a high
school kid of a heart being ripped apart
when he got rejected by this girl that
that or by all girls he said he was
beneath contempt he could he wasn't even
in the category of
comprehensible dating partner right he
was outside the game entirely so he's
rejected by the feminine as such he
draws these pictures of bird-headed
women with teeth you know with their
powerful big thighs big
big uh
big rear end like powerful physically
powerful intimidating women like mothers
draws sometimes these characters of
little tiny men
climbing up the legs of these huge
tree-like women
but they're very aggressive and and
and uh domineering and the reason for
that at least in part is because every
woman he ever
approached was
rejecting an aggressive in the extreme
treated him with nothing but contempt
and then he says in an unbelievably
memorable piece of the documentary
that all changed when i got successful
and you can just hear the resentment and
the bitterness in his voice even though
it did change and he wasn't that old
when he became successful he was in his
mid 20s you know plenty of time to be on
the outs completely and to experience
life at the bottom of the male dominance
hierarchy and even farther down the
female dominance hierarchy let's say in
terms of desirable men it's a it's
called crumb the documentary i would
highly recommend it and it's it's
absolutely brilliant studying and he had
well he had an authoritarian father and
uh indulgent mother and she plays
uh
a key role in the documentary and
uh it's it's awful it's it's awful it's
a it's a study in freudian
psychopathology that's deep
beyond belief i've seen it like 40 times
showing it to my classes and walking
through it clip by clip
but
but anyways it's a study you don't see
the world from the perspective of down
and out male loser
you know there are subcultures that that
sort of exist there but this is the this
is the only examination of that
place in the world i've ever seen that i
thought really really nailed it that the
documentarist was a friend of the family
so he and charles brothers one of them
ended up a sexual offender who lived on
the streets of san francisco and the
other committed suicide by drinking
furniture polish when he was like 55
after being bullied terribly in high
school and living in his mother's
basement essentially for his entire life
ugh
awful awful but you know you watch the
documentary it's not it's not like
people really
there's you you generate some compassion
for the people
in the documentary and what they've gone
through but i wouldn't say that
compassion is
what's primarily elicited by the
documentary and that goes back to this
discussion we had right at the beginning
about
you know what kind of
empathy we have for
the men who aren't making it and the
answer seems to be
very very little
let's go to social policy with that we
might ask okay in light of this what do
we do and i would say this is what i've
recommended i've recommended to young
men that they take that these are the
facts on the ground and they're not
going to change
and that
if you're being rejected chronically by
women or if you're terrified out of your
mind about that and and perhaps rightly
so
you should take a good hard look at
yourself and see what it is that you
have to offer and so
are you as educated as you could be are
you working you know are you looking for
a job at least are you trying to get out
of your parents house are you taking the
steps necessary to become
gainfully employed productive generous
and attractive
and
you know that tangles us back up with
something we also talked about in the
beginning which is the criticisms that
have been directed my way by men which
is well you're asking men to live up to
a stereotype that essentially
undermines and devalues the vast
majority of them you're part of the
problem not part of the solution and
your emphasis on
a responsible marriage given the state
of current family law is nothing short
of reprehensible and so you know my
approach is
do what you can at the individual level
to put yourself in the game but there's
there's much more to the story than that
absolutely this is really complex
because
the good news is there's a lot you can
do to choose a woman who is the right
woman
and so for example
uh looking at uh when when you go both
both go out to dinner um does she is is
she open to paying is she if she if she
isn't paying does she does she cook a
dinner for you the next time around um
how does she treat the waiter uh
somebody that can't do her um any any
good
um ask her about her uh former
relationships um how they broke um how
they broke up and who was at fault was
is there any accountability and
responsibility on her part of course ask
these same questions of yourself as well
especially about uh former relationships
and how they broke up um and um and so
that's um so choosing the right woman is
probably so what are you looking for
there you're looking for um
generosity you're looking for kindness
down the hierarchy right so that's how
does she treat people who are socially
inferior so to speak at least in that
context like waiters and then with
regards to previous relationships
is she capable of
some self-analysis or is is it always
the guy's fault that reminds me of that
atlantic monthly article one of them i'm
a fortune unfortunately can't remember
who wrote it but it was this woman in
her late 40s detailing out all the high
quality men that she had rejected many
many many men by her own
um
account and during the entire
article there wasn't any recognition
whatsoever of any time when it might
have been her
it was like i re these 40 men didn't
live up to my standards it's like well
after the fifth one didn't you start
thinking maybe the problem was on the
other side of the dating table but the
answer was obviously no and she was
obviously still single so
but so what are you looking for there
exactly and why did you why did you
bring that up at that point
uh well because
one of the ways that you can be involved
in the game of marriage in a way that is
positive um is by making the the choice
of the woman
differently than what we tend to do uh
we
many men look at a woman she's beautiful
and um and our desire to be sexual with
her uh leads us to sort of okay we'll
pay for dinner we'll promise this we'll
go we'll go here we'll go there we
should point out too i just want to
point out something i talked to randy
thornhill recently
one of the world's preeminent biologists
and
before we get to thinking that this
sexual attractiveness is nothing more
than mere shallow mindedness and
impulsive gratification is all the cues
of sexual attractiveness are tightly
associated with physical health and
fecundity which is the ability to
procreate and so even if men are blinded
by
beauty which which i do believe is
true enough
their reasons for that at the deepest
possible level still have to do with the
desire to continue the human species
so it's it's shallow in one sense but
not in another but your point is there
are other markers that are
characterological that are more subtle
that need to be taken into account
yes both sexes have very
um
huge reproductive draws i mean every
from an insect right on up through human
beings women tend to procreate and have
children with it with the out the alpha
male
a good example of this is buck elks and
among book elks um the females 85 of
them will have um reproduce with the
with the male that has the biggest wreck
um but the and that but what it takes to
get that biggest rack is an exhaustion
of 30 of the minerals nutrients and
calcium in the buck elk
so the second that he reproduces if he
doesn't get rid of his rack immediately
he's likely to die before winter sets in
and he's able to replenish the um the
nutrients and the and the minerals and
so on so his his his iraq was very
productive for being able to procreate
it was very productive for being able to
attract the female but it was also his
weakness that is and that's very
symbolic of men that men's weakness is
our facade of strength um because it was
strength because we could use that rack
or they not me but the buck elks could
use that rack to you know to get rid of
other predators or people that were the
female didn't want to protect the female
when she was um you know creating the
child and so on but once but he was also
being used uh for being part of the next
generations benefit of producing the
next generations machine and as you said
when we you know we once we have
children we really live for the next
generation and so
now the the next question becomes
as humans are we are do we want to
create more options for ourselves and so
and are we at a point now where survival
is mastered enough in the middle and
upper middle class that we have with
them then we are chosen
merely for our success and i think the
best explanation of that comes in japan
where the millennials in japan have a
game called karoshi and of course
karoshi means death at the desk or death
from overwork and the the game each
person has a little karoshi figure and
they compete to get to the top of the
ladder it might be the political ladder
might be the economic ladder it might be
the religious ladder and and as they
compete to get to the top of the ladder
the one who gets to the top of the
ladder first commits suicide not in real
life but in the game and the point that
the japanese millennials are
communicating with each other um is that
the
that what we did to become that
successful man who was a who was the
most attracted uh who was the most
able able to be eligible for sex and for
love um is we unbecame a human uh doing
um climbing to the top of the ladder
and we i'm sorry we unbecame a human
being we didn't even think of ourselves
as a human being that's why we're
committing suicide we have just just by
competing to be at the top of the ladder
we've worried about what position we
wanted how to working more hours um
pleasing the boss pleasing the
corporation um not not selling something
we wanted or doing something we wanted
and we we've lost we never even
considered ourselves as a human being
and so now we japanese millennials are
going to start looking at the um the
loss of ourselves as human doings uh
loss of ourselves rather as human beings
and that is um and that's the in my
opinion the
where we need to consider
going that as we have children where
there's this balancing act
of
do
helping our children see
the value of being that artist that
painter that's you know doing what you
love to do combined with
is it creating enough income to be
responsible to your family to do that
and and
and yes it will lose you some women but
if you're developing emotional skills
and emotional intelligence uh that may
not attract as many women as the
football player that risks his life and
spinal cord and injury but it may
attract the type of woman you want
and be for me between marriages when
when i would um go out uh with women
they would you know i would share with
them what i did
but part of that was sort of
redefining equality for them and it was
not offering to pay for the bill the
whole bill on the first date it was um
talking to them about the options like i
can pay on the first date and maybe you
can do something like cook dinner for me
on the second date uh type of thing but
i'll tell you many many times i feared
not many times i feared i know a few
times that i said something like that uh
that i knew there was going to be no sex
that evening whereas otherwise it
probably would have been and so um you
know it's a it's a risk that you take
inside of yourself
but for me what i wanted to select for
uh was a woman who wanted me more for
who i was and less for what status i had
or what predictable status i had
well what do you think what do you think
about the advice that i've
advised
i don't really think i give advice
exactly i'm trying to explore ideas and
that exploration has certain
consequences but certainly you know i do
and
as is my role as a psychologist i do
you know encourage
the people who are reading me to do what
they can with what they have to the best
of their ability and i don't see that we
have a
truly viable alternative to
essentially classic
sex roles i know they're under pressure
for all sorts of different reasons
including the ones that you've outlined
but
you know in some sense it's it's the
only game in town
now what can i mean there are things we
can do though you talked about um
japan for example where they've really
um
invested heavily in vocational training
which seems to me to be a no-brainer
it's like
maybe without having to revamp the
entire relationship between men and
women we could say well wouldn't it be
good social policy ev for everyone
concerned
to pay some attention to
the vast majority of men who
could use vocational training for
example as an avenue to success in all
domains of life and why are we so unable
to do that when the japanese can do it
yes and we really are
there there are so many things like that
that we can do i mean schools for
example um we could have one of the
things i've suggested to the white house
both of the trump administration and
also under the
biden administration is starting a male
teacher corps um in which
men are trained to be teachers
particularly in dad deprived areas uh
school districts and an extra and they
get free scholarships um they get full
scholarships uh for college but yet in
exchange for that full scholarship for
college they have to serve three or four
years as a teacher and a dad and a
school district that has few male
teachers um
another thing i've suggested to both
both so you think that's i'm thinking of
objections to that selection on the
basis of gender let's say which i'm you
know pretty much temperamentally opposed
to but
in some sense but this this is a
data-driven
suggestion
the data suggests that there are areas
that we so it's differentiated it's not
ideologically driven it's a
differentiated solution there are
there's data indicating that the
provision of male role models in places
that are deprived of those
um
the addition of male role models in in
the domains that are deprived of those
would be of benefit to everyone
concerned and so that's a targeted
social policy yes it's not an
ideological statement precisely and in
fact it's even more complex than that
the way that i've suggested it is that
you don't just get males like me i
consider myself more of a
nurturer connector male
you also get more traditional males so
that that no matter who your son is um
if you if you've grown up in a home
without a a male role model in the home
without a biological father particularly
in the home that you have that your son
no matter what he's prone toward what
his unique self is um that he's able to
go to find a role model find a role
model that is that it's not just another
nurture or connector male um but you
know a construction worker or i'm a a
man that's retired from a more of a um
a profession that was more traditional
like a locker or whatever firefighter
and that your son is able to see that
possibility and then also the nurturer
connector mail um as a possibility and
so that those things be uh offered
another suggestion that i think is by
far the most important one that i made
to both um administrations
um is the the importance of creating a
father
warrior program w-a-r-r um and and
because every gender you know
historically speaking as you as you read
in the boy crisis book about the purpose
void that men have uh if by no longer
being as needed as as soldiers and no
longer need being as needed as full-time
breadwinners uh that that the the male
have the option of seeing himself um as
pot as possibly and involved in um some
as i lost where i was going with that
you you were talking about the male
warrior idea and the need for purpose
and the social policy associated with
that
yes and so i i what i've suggested to
both white houses is the importance of
creating
a father warrior program where we're
saying we need young men to be full of
fully involved
learn all the traits of being a
responsible emotionally connected father
we need women to to value this in men as
well
um and so how would that work
practically speaking like i'm always
thinking about incentives like if we
wanted to incentivize young men to be
responsible fathers which i think is
exactly the right role to be playing in
every virtually every role that a man
plays is the role of responsible father
that's the right role not everyone but
virtually everyone
how do you incentivize that at the level
of social policy in in a practical way
the number one thing you do is you honor
it
so for example when we had each
generation had its war and we said uncle
sam needs you when men are told they are
needed that gives them purpose that
gives them drive that gives them honor
okay so how do we okay so how do we
um
say
fathers you are needed without saying
single mothers you're inadequate
because that's the killer right that's
the killer right there because one
implies the other or that's the theory
so
you know and this is uh this is a shoal
upon which our culture is is wrecking
itself is how do we reward
behavior that is
eminently pro-social in the broadest
possible sense of the word without
punishing simultaneously punishing those
who are
excluded from that but struggling to do
the best under the conditions that have
presented themselves to them
we say to mothers two things one is we
honor mothers for being just
overwhelmed i mean i've never
between marriages i dated a number of
almost all the women i dated were women
who had children the word that they used
most frequently was overwhelmed um and
the and so many of the mothers i tended
to date very bright women and so they
often felt caught between
they could do better
in work
they could go further they could go
farther uh they weren't up to their full
level but and they could do better as
mothers they felt guilty as mothers that
they didn't have enough time for their
work and they didn't have enough time
yes yes guilt all the time there
whatever they're doing is inadequate
exactly because they're not spending
enough time with their kids and they're
not spending enough time on their work
and both of those are true in some sense
absolutely and when they would they
would say i want to spend more time with
you but i'm caught between my work my um
the other trait and and and my and my
love interest and so um and so what the
the larger social message that needs to
come out come come out to men is
men
women need your help women do not
need not we
must not leave women uh to feel like so
is it women or mothers
mothers i'm sorry no it's okay i mean
it's just it's important to get it right
right i mean absolutely women you might
not need men's help mothers you do and
so do your children right exactly so
that you're so that when you focus on
mothers being overwhelmed
every mother hears that when you say to
a mother when a mother hears we're now
going to be emphasizing the importance
of dads getting in there to balance the
picture with you to help you out to be
to to to not have you have the entire
burden mothers do hear that in a
positive way
if you are simultaneously saying which i
think is 100 true
that you have just been that you've been
overwhelmed and you've been we respect
and honor the fact that you've you've
you've taken so much responsibility um
but it is not helpful for you to have to
be pulled in so many directions it is
not helpful for the children it's not
optimal for the children
it's not optimal for the children um and
it's not helpful for the dad because the
dad is experiencing a purpose void of
feeling not needed and unwanted and men
with purpose voids uh tend to
look for a purpose
yes tend to um
purpose and or um look for and be
negative sometimes in their purpose and
yes definitely we need to help mothers
and fathers in the whole country
understand okay so this sounds great so
why the hell don't you have any traction
with trump or with biden because that
pretty much exhausts the options so
what's going on well i you know with
with trump they uh the trump
administration said they were very
excited about it they asked me to write
up a speech that trump would give and he
never gave it um and so um any idea why
i mean
you'd think it would have been useful to
him you'd think
given his constituency i would have
thought it would have been 100 percent
useful to him i see i made the case that
there are about 20 million parents that
have children uh that
boys rather that are in failure to
launch mode in some way shape or form
and that these mothers care more about
their sons and they care about their
party label uh that this could open
until or themselves maybe even yes
exactly and i said this to both the
biden administration and the trump
administration uh the biden
administration was at least you know the
14 people that i met with at the white
house and with hhs uh they said uh they
were very all to a person extremely
enthusiastic
with the democrats i've gotten much more
of a resistance when the white house
counsel on gender policy was created and
i objected to that not including boys
and men and fathers um and and said that
you couldn't possibly say you were in
favor of diversity and inclusion when
you excluded fathers and boys and men
and then they said that it's only 50 of
the population yes yes or 49 is the
percent or whatever
but you know but it's one thing if you
just say boys and men are not important
it's another thing to say i'm in favor
of diversity and inclusion and then to
say that the second mission of the
gender policy council
is to have racial justice
and not understand that racial justice
can that the single biggest group of
people who are having challenges in the
culture are black males and you know if
you if you go to a homeless citizen
which is a prime example of the
intersectionality that's being touted as
crucial to the development of our entire
culture yes yes and here
it's the prime example perhaps indeed
here because i think black women are
outperforming black men on average in
almost every metric yes yes
exactly so so you know
well that does beg the question
mean what question does it beg well
maybe one question it begs is where
exactly is the systemic racism
the the racism use a horrible phrase
yes i don't even want to go to systemic
racism but if if the
if the goal of the white house gender
policy council
is to have racial justice as it says it
is
then you would
but then they go ahead and exclude
black males
from racial justice and only focus on
black females
that is undermining racial justice
because these as we know since the 1965
with the moynihan report um the when we
did studies of inner city crime and the
fear when uh patrick moynihan went to do
that study was oh my goodness he's gonna
be blaming black people is gonna be
racist in fact he ended up finding that
it was not blacks per se
uh that were creating the crime it was
just that 125 at that point in history
in 1965 it was only 25
of the children who were being raised in
families um were without father
involvement and almost all of the crimes
that were being committed were from the
the dead deprived children well now yeah
that hasn't changed
that well that hasn't changed except one
thing has changed the percentage of
children who are raised in dad deprived
mode in the black community has gone way
up 25 what do you think of the counter
arguments to that that have been raised
recently that black men are just as
involved with their children it's just
that it's in ways that the you know
privileged
white community
jesus christ
isn't recognizing and that that's just
another form that idea that you know the
black father is less engaged is just
another racist trope
no some black father there are um a
significant number of black fathers who
are involved with their children
that is not where those children those
are not the children that are having
problems as long as the black mother is
also involved with the children um so
when whenever you have that um and of
course the the social policies we were
talking about before you know the of of
giving
money to the women infants and children
program another program where the the
female who did the black female or the
white female who did not have um a
father in the home she would be helped
and if the father was not in the home
that did reinforce very significantly uh
the propensity of the mother to say
let's say the father wasn't earning very
much money so the father would if you if
you live away from me uh we'll be able
to get government support and so then
that right incentive for living right
watch your incentives right and we have
to realize today it's not just that the
um african-american families
now have more than 70 of the children
who are raised with minimal or no father
involvement or what i call dead deprived
children but also at the time of the
moynihan report in 1965 there was only
3.2 percent of caucasian families whose
children were living in dad deprived
situations now that's gone up to 35 in
caucasian families and so we had this
enormous dad deprivation in it's in
these dad deprived
families that um
watch what's going to happen in the fall
we're going to have significant numbers
of school shootings and one of the
things that we see with school shooters
in the in the 21st century every school
shooter who shot 10 or more people
killed 10 or more people every one of
them was dad deprived
we um when we look at when you look at
the prison population it's 93 male and
the great majority of those males are
dead deprived males um i i think i've
never experienced something that was
more touching for me than when i ran for
governor and i spoke of california and i
spoke around that a few prison
populations and i talked to these prison
populations almost all male the first
question i would ask is you know how
many of you had an involved father in
about three or four percent of the hands
of the prison population but would go up
and then i would talk to them about all
the
the things that dads do that are
different from what moms tend to do like
the teasing like the postponed
ratification like the rough housing and
what the psychological value of those
were for the children's growth and
development and i had these guys with
tattoos and um you know muscles that
i'll never have
coming up to me and saying you're crying
and saying i never realized i was worth
anything i thought i was better off
probably in prison because i was the
worthless per person in the family and
suddenly for the first time i'm feeling
like i want to get out of prison to help
my children uh not have the problems
that i had and not go and not make the
mistakes that i made um and so there's
this enormous desire on the part of the
men
to know that they're valuable as fathers
you know my my sense as a clinical
psychologist has always been that
a kid has to have one role model
sometime in their life to to make it
they have to have someone to mimic or
they can't make it now you can get that
a variety of ways i remember reading
angela's ashes it's great book by frank
mccourt and his dad was a recalcitrant
alcoholic who drank the family's
livelihood and health away it was awful
but he kind of separated his dad into
good
dad and bad dad and bad dad was drunk
evening dad and good dad was sober
morning dad and he got his mimicry from
good sober morning dad you know so you
can you can pick it up in bits and
pieces from different places but
if you're
even if you have an intact nervous
system you know and you're not suffering
from burdens right at the point of your
birth
from from deprivation that's that began
before you were even around
you need to have at least one model in
your life that shows you what the good
version of you could be because
otherwise how the hell do you know what
it is
and it needs to be embodied right so you
can see it play itself out so then you
can play with it
yes absolutely let me and let me to that
effect let me address the the females in
the audience here listening to this that
are single moms and and what can you do
so the number one thing that that you
can do is take a look at the differences
between
dad style parenting and mom style
parenting because oftentimes the things
that dads do
look like they're not caring about the
children the things like teasing the
things like rough housing the things
that letting the children take risks
like you know climbing the trees like we
talked about they all seem like um this
the tough love decisions are often seen
you see the toughness without the love
very frequently and so um
take a very careful look at that make
sure that if you're still if you still
have the data all around are available
that you get into family dinner nice
discussions where everybody um learns
how to listen to everybody else's
perspective in the family uh learn how
to do a negotiating of that that uh
checks and balance parenting but if it's
absolutely impossible to get the
biological father involved and i'm
afraid that the biological father
children do better with the biological
father than they do with a stepfather
mostly stepparent elevates risk for
abuse by a hundred fold if i remember
correctly it's a very um stepfathers
almost always are never allowed to be
more than advisors if you do have a
stepfather
work on that issue that i talk about in
the boy crisis book on how to
engage the sec the stepfather as a real
equal assuming that he's a responsible
and loving man
but if all those things fail
make sure you get your child at the age
appropriate time into cub scouts cub
scouts involved children involved in cub
scouts for two or more years uh have a
very significant increase in character
development over children that are
involved in cubs scouts minimally uh and
or not at all
boy scouts are a wonderful construct
deconstruction of masculinity they've
really figured out how to bring out the
best in boys
faith-based communities children who are
in faith-based communities make sure
your faith-based leader gets your son
involved with other uh in small groups
with other boys his age and make sure he
that he encourages your son to be um
and all the boys in the group to talk
about their feelings and their fears um
so that they can see that they're not
alone in those feelings and fears
make sure your children are involved in
the what i call the liberal arts of
sports but by the liberal arts and
sports i mean team sports
also pick up team sports
uh which uh and and also sports where
you have to develop your own skills it's
you're part of a team like in gymnastics
or in tennis but you're not interacting
with the team all the time each of those
things will develop in your son
different types of skill sets the most
important one that oftentimes moms don't
realize the value of
is the value of pick up team sports let
your son or daughter be at a at a
at the school without your supervision
let them pick up a game where they have
to decide without somebody supervising
them um how big the court should be at
the basketball court should be should be
half size full size one of the fouling
rules who do you check uh check is
perfect um
developmental skills for being an
entrepreneur and being being able to
make decisions without supervision
obviously team sports are pretty obvious
what their benefits are and um and
developing skills without that are
dependent on this team are part of the
liberal arts and sports so spend time in
the boy crisis book but looking at what
you can do
as a single as a single yeah well one of
the things i liked about your books and
and
why men earn more as well is that
they're
full of information but they're also
practical and they have practical advice
here's things you can actually do which
is something people apparently
appreciate about my books so it's nice
to have it detailed down to the level of
action i want to close because i know
we're we've exhausted you um what why
did you receive such
i would like to know why you think you
didn't get more traction with the trump
people but then i would like you to tell
me what's up with the democrats why
didn't you get
why did you get rejected so out of hand
when you put forward these perfectly
reasonable propositions which in
principle should be in accordance with
what they're claiming to support
yes even the trump people this is what
i'm going to say now is ten times
tenfold this issue with the biden people
but even the trump people were fearful
that the single mother would feel
criticized and they were afraid of
losing that the support from her
and um and so that was that was what i
heard behind the scenes was the
the gap between
um it being very much recommended by the
people that i spoke with versus actually
having a a presentation delivered by
trump the other thing was that
they were fearful that it would it would
call attention to trump's failed
marriages and um
and his his womanizing and they didn't
want to open that door so those were the
chain okay
from the biden side um it was like it
was well the best example of this is
when i went to iowa and i interviewed
nine of the presidential candidates that
were democrats and most of them um were
very excited especially andrew yang and
um
senator hickenlooper john hickenlooper
were very excited about what i was
saying andrew yang already had a mastery
of what was um what the problems were
with boys
he was on the tip of maybe being able
potentially to talk about the issue
um
while when i finished talking with both
andrew yang and um and hickenlooper um
especially with andrew yang the female
campaign manager came up to me and said
i'm sorry warren we just cannot have him
talk about these issues this will
alienate our feminist base this will
alienate uh women who are single moms um
it will not and we want we want also
many of the women who are divorced
we want them not to feel that they won't
have the choice of going off and
starting a new life and
bringing their children to a new
location with a new man um and so we are
afraid of losing that those two yes well
into hell with the old man yes
and so it was really um and that they
were honest with me that's the good news
the bad news is
that
this was the case and so with when the
biden administration um created the
white house gender policy council which
was a day or two before he was actually
inaugurated um the um and it was focused
on you know women and girls and um you
know and and both black women and girls
and white women and girls i protested
and um and
talked with jen klein who was the
co-chair about this
many times and her only answer over and
over again is warren um president biden
cares about men and boys warren what
president biden cares about the fathers
and my responses my my constant
hammering of her about well then then it
should be written into the white house
gender policy council to create these
father warrior programs to create these
um
these programs of dozens of which i
suggested uh that could uh increase and
improve the lives of boys and men and i
was met with
no answer
like just so what what's the problem
what's the problem as far as you're
concerned we might as well have it right
out what the hell is going on in in jen
klein's case and in the um and the
feminist uh in the the liberal political
leadership
and the democrats it is just a
fundamentally and totally honest belief
that um women have it worse than men
that boys and men and the constant image
that comes up for
the political liberals is warren right
so it's the gen it's the classification
of the world by sex that's the problem
it isn't who has problems and how do we
help them it's it's the classification
first and the problem second it's we
live in a patriarchal world dominated by
men who made the rules to benefit men at
the expense of women the proof of that
is that um look at who's at the top of
the political ladder look at who's the
top of the
corporate ladder uh look at who's the
top of even the religious level right so
it's right back to where we started
which is identify that tiny minority of
men who are hyper successful generalize
that to the masculine
uh universe at large and to hell with
those that are in the middle or the
bottom which is
so what is that hypergamy in female
politics
is it the same thing and it is not the
realization that the men at the top
are often at the top they're earning
that more money not because they feel
more fulfilled or this is their choice
they felt obligated to earn money that
somebody else spent while they died
sooner right so it's not even true for
the people who have the privilege much
less true for men anywhere else on the
hierarchy correct and when i say to them
things like you know it isn't male
privilege do you consider it male
privilege for every um generation during
their war to train the boys and the men
uh to be the ones that died in war so
that you could be protected and saved
and it's just like
closed mouth uh what about the um the
legislation that's become a real issue
in korea
south korea i oh actually i didn't know
that oh yes yes there are no shortage of
men who are not thrilled about the fact
that they are conscripted for two years
and the women aren't now you know my
sense is well the women pay their dues
in childbirth and pregnancy and you know
but nonetheless it's it's an issue and
it's producing no shortage of resentment
and friction among young koreans
and here in the united states you know
it's still the law
um which is probably the most
unconstitutional law that most violates
the 14th amendment's equal protection
laws it is still the law in the united
states that your son who's 18
must register for the draft if he
doesn't um he's could be fined a quarter
million dollars he could be put in
prison for a year or two he can heal in
42 states he can lose his driver's
license if he doesn't register for the
draft um he and there's a whole series
of other he could never go to a school
that gets federal money which is
virtually every school including private
schools this is all the punishment that
men have male your son has if he's 18
and doesn't register for the draft the
punishment for females is zero because
they don't have to register for the
draft they have the option to so what do
you think of that warren like they the
old-fashioned patriarchal part of me
thinks
i think two ways at the same time you
know unfortunately about that i think
you know
i do believe to some degree that that's
the balancing of the scales you know
that as you pointed out in your own book
you know men die in war and women die in
childbirth now they don't die in
childbirth so much anymore but they did
and and in in great numbers and it was
terrible pain and and and all of the
privation that went along with that
obligatory responsibility tremendous
amount of that has been ameliorated not
all of it but a tremendous amount thank
god for technological progress and so
but
having said that well
it doesn't sit well the idea of women
drafted for frontline combat doesn't sit
well with me yes and i think there's an
answer to that which is we don't have to
draft people for frontline combat there
are there are there are men that are not
suited to that there are women that are
not suited to that but we're either but
i think it's
a good solution would be either you
don't have registration for the draft
which creates a different set of
problems with not having a ready
group ready but say you but you have
people register at the age of 18 for
some type of service of say six months
or more and and and then you you mark
off the type of service that your
personality that your that your um
contribution can make you could be a
healthcare frontline worker you can be a
volunteer in this way or that way so if
there's mandatory service it's mandatory
for all but the service itself can
differ
and and and everyone could have some
choice in that and who knows maybe
there'd be enough people pick frontline
combat to fill the necessary places it's
possible i mean there are people who are
constitutionally
inclined towards that and if there isn't
enough people for that then you do a
supply and demand type of phenomenon you
raise the income for the people who do
um
right right right which would be that
would right exactly that would be the
equitable way of dealing with it is is
increase the hazard pay yes exactly
right and you'd watch the demand in
you'd watch the supply increase exactly
because there'd be people who are right
on the line right right on the edge
exactly right right right right
any final things to say
yeah i guess maybe the most important
thing i'd like
us to all get is that there are so many
things like hashtag me too
that are so valuable um
for us to hear the pain and the
experience that women go through
but hashtag me too as a monologue
is a disaster
because it needs to be a dialogue
yeah just like it needs to be a dialogue
between men and women in a family
exactly we need to hear that that men
have pain men have all these these
children
the 50-plus developmental challenges
that i talk about that men feel um
lonely isolated that men why men suffer
more
because when and because one thing we
need to do it
just for compassion
secondly there's so many
misunderstandings and
anger that is happening by
we say on the one hand
men are we have toxic masculinity
they don't express their feelings they
don't say who they are and then we we
make men pay an enormous price when they
do express their feelings and so so many
young men feel caught between a rock and
a hard place yes well i would say that's
happened in my case you know because i
have this unfortunate proclivity to
burst into tears at the slightest
provocation which has haunted me my
entire life but is still quite
pronounced and it isn't exactly obvious
to me that you know my radical left-wing
critics are above using that as a weapon
it's quite interesting to note you know
and maybe they're justified in doing so
i'm not saying that that's but that's it
runs contrary to their hypothetical
theory yes yes exactly and you know and
i've said man after man by the way i
have the exact same character as if my
if my wife were here listening now she'd
be really chuckling because uh anything
that is you know what i had to hold
myself back when i was talking about the
memory of the of the men in the prison
population coming up to me afterwards
and themselves crying um right right
yeah i think you just both got me there
too
the hashtag me to dialogue is
is so important not just for empathy um
but also because to to eradicate the
toxic part of masculinity that keeps
feelings all to oneself because when you
do that you end up having a volcano
built inside of you and it comes out as
the anger it comes out as distance it
comes out as drinking it comes out in
destructive behavior and it also comes
out in things like school shootings mass
shootings
committing crimes and so both to protect
ourselves from the mass shootings from
the isis recruits almost all of whom are
dead deprived males and females um and
also adam is there data is there data on
that warren with regards to
recruitment for
yes there is a fact it was done
by three sociologists who looked at
the studied isis recruits in lebanon and
after doing that um they
anecdotally told each other afterwards
you know a lot of these these guys have
um
don't have their dads and they were
trying to
get involved with isis to have some
sense of purpose beyond themselves and
wealth was never part of our
questionnaire they went back and then
did a systematic study of the men asking
including that question that had not
been asked at the at the beginning and
found that to be the single most common
denominator of the isis recruits uh by
the way there's um
89 male isis recruits at 11 female isis
recruits and the females had deprivation
as an issue um as well as the males as
the single biggest
characteristic
patriarchal ideology as a substitute for
paternal relationship
yes yes absolutely and just a need to
have some sense of purpose
and feeling of being needed and that's
one of the things that dads are so good
at as working with moms moms are so good
at identifying a child's gifts
nurturing the child's gifts and dads are
so good at the tough love often times
that are necessary to help the child um
achieve those gifts yeah well i thought
you know it seems to me that the central
characteristic of the
benevolent paternal spirit parodied as
the patriarchy is encouragement
oh encourage well i would i said i think
i take a little bit of a different issue
there i think moms and dads both
encourage a lot um but moms oftentimes
repeat the encouragement
and when the child fails are still
encouraging
whereas the dads say if you want to get
to that outcome
you need to not do that texting you need
not to you know do all the things that
that outcome requires and they tend to
sort of enforce those boundaries and
hold the child accountable uh to a
greater degree does that make sense sure
sure that's
thank you very much for talking with me
today it's just much much appreciated
you don't exhaust me you energized me i
just said oh well i'm glad to hear that
and i hope that i hope that everybody
finds this conversation useful thank you
thanks again
thank you
[Music]
you